phoenix vor ort
tag vier nach der bundestagswahl und
alles ist im fluss allerhand abstimmungs
termine zwischen den verschiedenen
parteien und fraktionen untereinander
auf dem weg zu einer neuen
bundesregierung irgendwann in einigen
wochen eher monaten wahrscheinlich
darüber müssen wir sprechen herzlich
willkommen meine damen und herren an
diesem donnerstagmorgen zu phoenix vor
ort morgen also das nächste treffen
zwischen grünen und der fdp in größerer
runde dann wird zum deutlich mehr themen
gehen als beim ersten vor sondierungs
kennenlernen am dienstagabend sie haben
das self gesehen am sonntag trefen grüne
und fdp dann die spd aber erst mal
jeweils alleine und nicht gemeinsam fdp
und grüne scheinen also die eine
zeitlichen ablauf erst mal im griff zu
haben aber wie sieht es eigentlich mit
gemeinsamen inhalten aus
man die wahlprogramme von grünen und fdp
so lassen sie sich scheinbar leicht zu
einem gesamtbild zusammenfügen auf den
zweiten blick wird es komplizierter
thema klima die grünen wollen tempolimit
130 den kohleausstieg auf 20 30
vorziehen und ab dann nur noch komplett
emissionsfreie autos zu lassen die fdp
möchte kein tempolimit kohleausstieg bei
20 38 erstmal belassen und auf die
innovationskraft der autoindustrie
vertrauen ein kompromiss thema könnte
der emissionshandel seien auf den setzt
die fdp als instrument des marktes und
den grünen könnte es die chance bieten
durch teure zertifikate den co2 preis zu
erhöhen gut für das klima auch zwischen
den parteien
thema geld die fdp will auf keinen fall
die schuldenbremse aufweichen und auch
nicht die steuern erhöhen die grünen
wollen geld für klimaschutz
investitionen und die steuern für
kleinere und mittlere einkommen senken
für größere einkommen und vermögen
anheben hier ist ein kompromiss
schwierig möglich sind aber wohl klima
investitionen die über sonderwege
finanziert werden also nicht gegen die
schuldenbremse verstoßen und dann noch
das thema gesundheit hier wollen die
grünen eine bürgerversicherung für alle
einführen die fdp am bestehenden system
von privaten und gesetzlichen kassen
festhalten einigung in diesem punkt wohl
schwierig
als bürgerliche parteien gibt es
allerdings auch gemeinsames bei den
bürgerrechten der gleichberechtigung der
digitalen bildung dem datenschutz der
integration den wählerschichten und
wahrscheinlich auch dem wunsch bald
endlich wieder zu regieren
auf die inhaltlichen überschneidungen
von grünen und linken wollen wir gerne
jetzt schauen zusammen mit gerhard baum
dem letzten bundesinnenminister den die
fdp in einer regierung gestellt hat vor
knapp 40 jahren in der spd geführten
regierung von helmut schmidt 1978 bis 82
für muntari baum
guten morgen herr warum sie haben die
zusammenarbeit mit den grünen gestern
nacht bei meinem kollegen markus lanz im
zdf als projekt bezeichnet was ist für
sie ein projekt
ja also beide parteien sind nicht teil
der großen koalition gewesen sie stehen
also licht für den status quo sondern
für etwas neues und sehr interessant ist
dass sie bei jung und erstwählern sehr
guten abgeschnitten haben sie haben
einen zukunfts auftrag das heißt also
sie müssen jetzt die linien bestimmen
über die einzelheiten wird man dann im
einzelnen auch streiten aber die linie
muss stimmen dass wir die zukunft
sichern in sachen umwelt europa an alten
themen die jetzt dringend behandelt
werden müssen und es kommt noch etwas
hinzu was soll denn passieren wenn die
beiden jetzt scheitern dann ist ja im
grunde
fällt alles in sich zusammen das heißt
sie sind auch in gewisser hinsicht zu
einem erfolg verurteilt und ich sehe die
chancen gar nicht so schlecht denn es
bewegt sich etwas in der gesellschaft
die neue parteien struktur wird sichtbar
es ist eine vielfalt die uns jetzt hier
begegnen in der gesellschaft sind riesen
probleme in der welt in europa in
deutschland alles ist ein 1 1 mutti
wallander motivation jetzt ein projekt
zu machen also nicht nur einzelne
forderungen abzuhaken sondern das in ein
gesamtkonzept zu gießen in eine
richtungsentscheidung für die zukunft
also hermann sie sagen sie sagen
wahrzeichen von den großen linien herr
baum was sind denn diese großen linien
wo sie sagen da sind grün und fdp auf
einer linie und wo sagen sie nein da ist
man doch weit voneinander entfernt da
muss man sich erst auf eine linie egal
da muss da muss man sich auf eine linie
einigen zum beispiel in dem
spannungsverhältnis was macht der markt
was macht der staat ich sehe da keine
unüberwindbaren hinderungsgründe es ist
ja jetzt das ziel beispielsweise die
umweltkatastrophe zu vermeiden da geht
es darum wie erreicht man das ziel am
besten und da meine ich musste sich
beide bewegen der markt schafft nicht
alles aber mit mit regeln wird man auch
nicht alles schafft man braucht die die
kräfte der wirtschaft die kräfte die
idee das einzelne individuum aufbringen
muss und um die zukunft mitzugestalten
also ich bin wirklich relativ
optimistisch sehr gut und sagt ja das
ist doch schon mal gut an und fangen wir
brauchen wenn ich da rein gretchen darf
er bleiben wir doch mal ganz konkret
also hast du die fdp sagt ganz klar
schuldenbremse bleibt die grünen sagen
ja auch wir wollen die schuldengrenze
nicht auf brennen sie nicht aufweichen
aber wir wollen deutlich mehr
investitionen als das vielleicht die fdp
will wie geht das sozusagen
sinnvolle investition will jedoch nicht
wie wollen sie habe voll investitionen
in bildung in unserer infrastruktur wir
wollen sinnvolle investitionen die also
das land dauerhaft
in die zukunft bringen und da wird man
sich doch einige
visa an bürger schultern nicht merkten
dann wenn ich da kurz rein greifen darf
wenn wir ist es bei der
krankenversicherung da möchte die
möchten die grünen gerne eine
bürgerversicherung also alle zahlen in
die gleiche krankenversicherung ein
während sie während die fdp ganz nah
sagt nein dieses system gesetzliche und
private krankenversicherungen das wollen
wir so beibehalten das ist ja ein
diametralen gegensatz ja
ja das wird schwierig und da wird man
genau rechnen müssen und man wird auch
prinzipien zur disposition stellen wir
haben eine andere annäherung an die an
die lösung als die grünen und dass das
sind ich will gar nicht verschweigen es
gibt auch schwierige probleme aber ich
glaube die tatsache dass man sich jetzt
von eingefahrenen gleisen weg bewegen
musste etwas gemeinsam zu etwas neuem
dieser druck ist da und wenn die
parteien das bestehen sozusagen die
beiden kleineren
nuclos der neuen koalition dann wird
ihnen das beiden helfen und die und
weiter voranbringen ich bin fest
überzeugt
dieser druck der jetzt auch der
zeitliche druck der besteht wird zur
lösung führen ich meine den druck gab es
vorher vier jahren ja auch damals hat
man sich dann trotzdem nicht da
eigentlich beziehungsweise christian
lindner hat trotzdem zurückgezogen was
sagt denn uns allen wer sagt denn uns
allen jetzt dass christian lindner nicht
dass dieses jahr wieder so macht
das scheitern von jamaika ist ein trauma
und es bestimmt auch jetzt den gang der
dinge man will auf keinen fall sich so
verhält wie das 2017 geschehen ist das
ist auch ein gutes vorzeichen man will
die fehler vermeiden nicht wahr dass das
gilt auch für die für die spd man wird
jetzt genau ich aufpassen müssen was
passiert eigentlich in den fraktionen
nicht wahr die vielen neuen mitglieder
bei der wahl der spd beispielsweise sind
die ein unsicherheitsfaktor was passiert
bei den grünen liegen die fdp ist
ziemlich stabil also geben wir jetzt mal
davon aus das ist ein bekanntes scholz
gibt aber das ist ja auch noch nicht aus
gehören herr baum ich meinen sie sie
haben ja einst den linksliberalen
freiburger kreis innerhalb der fdp
gegründet ich gehe also wahrscheinlich
recht in der annahme dass sie
wahrscheinlich doch die ampel er
präferiere noever jamaika ist es aus
ihrer sicht so dass wenn es hier nicht
zu einer ampel kommt und zu einer
einigung dann steht für sie auch
christian lindner als parteichef infrage
das steht überhaupt nicht zur debatte
als mann der da wird sich wie die
anderen bemühen jetzt zu einer einigung
zu kommen ich mache keinen hehl aus
meiner meinung ich war immer ein
anhänger des sozialen liberalismus wie
dem in dem freibad legendären freiburger
programm vor 50 jahren das zum ausdruck
gekommen ist also mit mit auch mit
kritik überhaupt an auswüchsen des
kapitalismus
und wir waren die erste umweltpartei ich
war ja auch umweltminister das kann und
muss man meines erachtens wiederbeleben
das wird der fdp gut tun inwiefern gut
tun
weil sie weil sie es jetzt sichtbar ihre
thematische spektrum wieder arbeiter das
hat sie schon längst getan in der
fraktion gibt es kräftige jüngere kräfte
fachleute menschen die sich engagieren
auf dem feld der umweltpolitik der
bürgerrechte und so wie jetzt die jetzt
ja auch sichtbarer werden die fdp hat
die zeit genutzt der opposition und es
ist eine eine eine führungsriege
nachgewachsen die jetzt auch sichtbarer
werden wird und sichtbarer werden muss
gerhart baum wenn ich das liebevoll
sagen darf ein urgestein der fdp
fehlende angehen herr baum hier im
phoenix tagesgespräch
ja noch schönen tag in auch der baum so
und dabei vergisst man fast die union
cdu und csu nur 1,6 prozent hinter der
spd abgeschnitten bei der bundestagswahl
am sonntag aber werden die
fraktionsvorsitzenden der grünen gering
eckert den zeitungen der funke
mediengruppe sagt die union sei nicht
sondierungs fähig und schon gar nicht
regierungsfähig dann klingt das schon
hart aber viele bei der union würden wie
viele stellt sich die frage wie viele
würden widersprechen bei dem zwist den
es derzeit gibt zwischen den
schwesterparteien cdu und csu
die wortwahl auf der wand sagt schon
alles csu im bundestag manche in der cdu
regt allein das auf schließlich sei man
doch eine fraktion eine union csu chef
würde aber lässt kaum eine gelegenheit
aus gegen den glücklosen
kanzlerkandidaten armin laschet zu
sticheln noch dazu geriert er sich als
retter der union in der so söder gerade
große nervosität und anspannung
herrschen da wird so unsere aufgabe sein
in dieser aufgeregten zeit auch in der
union stückweit ordnung und linien und
vertrauen und zusammenhalt zu
stabilisieren sich von der kleineren
schwester den takt vorgeben lassen diese
machtbewusste ansage kommt in der cdu
gar nicht gut an die cdu ist selber
stabil wir haben starke
ministerpräsidenten von schleswig
holstein bis sachsen oder saarland wir
haben mehrere führungspersonen auch in
der cdu bundestagsfraktion
und deswegen brauchen wir keine weitere
unterstützung aus bayern für die
stabilisierung der union nach den
dramatischen verlusten am sonntag sind
natürlich beide unionsschwestern
verantwortlich und zuständig das ist
eine gemeinschaftsaufgabe die wir auch
gemeinsam bewältigen müssen das mit der
gemeinsamkeit von cdu/csu scheint so
eine sache zu sein wahlkampfabschluss
der union vergangenen freitag da war die
hoffnung noch groß und die welt in
ordnung jetzt herrscht katerstimmung und
mit der geselligkeit ist es vorbei
sprechen wir mit eckart lohse dem leiter
der parlamentsredaktion der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung halle lose
herr lohse sprechen wir über das
stichwort einigkeit ist ja vielleicht so
was wie ein überbegriff über diese tage
nach der bundestagswahl um bleiben gerne
bei der union die wir eben auch im
beitrag gesehen haben also einigkeit
besteht ja da nicht allzu viel zu geben
wie bewerten sie das was gerade in der
union passiert also man hat das ja schon
in den letzten drei jahren sehen können
die einigkeit ging verloren als angela
merkel angekündigt hat dass sie nicht
mehr vorsitzen sein will aber noch drei
jahre kanzlerin und inside dieser
strecke hat die union ist nicht mehr
geschafft im streit zwischen cdu und csu
aber auch innerhalb der cdu eine einige
linie zu finden jetzt eskaliert das ja
geradezu erst mit der streit über die
kanzlerkandidatur die söder und laschet
beide haben wollten und jetzt nach dem
schlechten wahlergebnis wird es
eigentlich immer dramatischer vor allen
dingen von csu seiten von söder seiten
aus dass er immer wenn vielleicht ein
bisschen beruhigung einkehrt sofort die
wunde wieder aufreißt ich kann es auch
verstehen dass andere parteien sagen da
wären wir skeptisch ob wir mit denen
überhaupt solide vorhand und führen
können weil wir gar nicht genau wissen
wir hatten da eigentlich prokura bei
denen es ist ja so weit gegangen dass
gestern abend volker wissing der
generalsekretär der fdp im heute journal
gesagt hat also diese einladung die die
fdp an die union ausgesprochen hat sich
am samstag zu treffen zu der würde es
wohl nicht kommen weil die union ich
zitiere das mal zeit probleme hätte oder
organisatorische probleme
wie kann das sein wie kann an einem
samstag etwas wichtigeres geben für die
union als ich mit der fdp über mögliche
sondierung für die zukunft zu
unterhalten ja das kann überhaupt nicht
sein das kann höchstens sein dass nicht
klar ist wer in der union diese
verhandlungen dann führt wer die nummer
eins ist die frage wird ja auch immer
wieder gestellt an den laschen
beansprucht natürlich diese rolle für
sich er war der kanzlerkandidat er kann
das überhaupt nur machen aber wenn wir
die worte söders von vorgestern uns noch
mal in erinnerung bringen dann hat er ja
auch deutlich gemacht dass die csu dass
er da eine rolle sich vorstellen kann er
war zwar von einer matrix die rede die
die csu bereits für solche verhandlungen
habe das ist natürlich so etwas
öffentlich vorzutragen bevor der
kanzlerkandidat etwas dazu sagt ist
natürlich auch eine provokation und nur
so kann es zu solchen schwierigkeiten
kommen herr lohse also braucht man armin
laschet jetzt noch für diese gespräche
mit der fdp weil eben auch dieses
verhältnis verhältnis laschet lindner so
eng ist und danach ist anderen weg
also eins ist ja klar jetzt braucht man
ihn auf jeden fall wenn die union jetzt
ist die cdu dann die csu zweifel daran
aufkommen lässt wer da der
kanzlerkandidat war wer der vorsitzende
ist und wer solche gespräche ganz gleich
wohin sie führen führt ich glaube dann
muss sie gar nicht mehr sich um
gesprächspartner bemühen es muss klar
sein dass das ohne streit dass man ohne
streit zumindest diese ersten
sondierungen führt das scheint ja schon
schwierig zu sein was dann daraus so das
ist höchst ungewiss übrigens hört man
das ja auch in der cdu schon dass das
die hoffnung das ist zu einer jamaika
koalition kommt nicht gerade wachsen im
moment aber wenn jetzt eine demontage
jetzt die ja gegen dessen willen
stattfände käme also dann wäre der
streit perfekt und dann würde ich glaube
ich jede partei gesagt mit denen lieber
nicht verhandeln würde ich verstehen
guckt mal von der union weg und schauen
mal zu den bei neuen man denkt ja fast
schon lieblingspartnern grünen und fdp
wie groß ist denn die einigkeit
tatsächlich in den letzten wochen
monaten vielleicht auch jahren geworden
nach diesem eklat 2017 als christian
lindner sich hier aus den
sondierungsgesprächen aus den gesprächen
zu einer neuen koalition zurückgezogen
hat man habe immer gesprächskontakt
gehalten man hat natürlich
in beiden parteien bewusst sie sehen ja
auch die zahlen dass die möglichkeit
eines dreierbündnisses nach der wahl
jetzt
vorhanden ist das war klar sein
zwischenzeitlich mal nach option
schwarz-grün aus aber man kann sich ja
darauf vorbereiten dreierbündnis ist
möglich daher immer kontakte gehalten
werden sie haben es ja eben in der
sendung auch schon aufgearbeitet es gibt
natürlich einige inhaltliche differenzen
einige schnittstellen gerade die
rechtspolitik die rechtsstaats politik
da ist manches wo man zusammenkommen
kann bildungspolitik aber es gibt
natürlich beisteuern sozialpolitik da
ist es fraglich es gab in der
asylpolitik große unterschiede aber
vergessen wenn ich zwei jahre nach dem
großen
flüchtlingsstreit 215 haben ja fdp und
grüne 217 miteinander verhandelt und
gescheitert ist das ganze nicht daran
dass die beiden sich zerlegt haben
sondern dass lindner angst hatte dass
die damals einige cdu unter angela
merkel sich zu sehr auf die grünen
einlässt ist wahr wenn nicht das
hauptproblem dass fdp und grüne nicht
zusammengekommen also da teile ich die
einschätzung von ihrem gesprächspartner
gerd warum eben dass wenn die schon
hinkriegen aber doch immer die gleiche
wollte ich eben auch gerd baum gestellt
haben die sich dann doch auch an ihre
ausführungen doch anlehnt nämlich die
frage wer sagt uns denn dass christian
gentner nicht diesmal wieder das gleiche
gespür und gefühle hat zumal die spd und
grüne sicher näher sind als cdu und
grüne damals 2017 union und grüne 2017
der riesen unterschied ist zwischen
lindner und merkel bestand ein
ausgesprochen spannungsreiches
verhältnis vor allen dingen merkel hatte
einen sehr negativen blick auf lindner
das wusste er
das verhältnis war angespannt und
lindner hatte angst dass die mächtige
cdu chefin und kanzlerin ihn als 566 rad
am wagen behandelt das ist jetzt ganz
anders erstens lindner an laschet haben
ein gutes verhältnis nicht zuletzt durch
das regieren in nordrhein-westfalen in
einer schwarz-gelben regierung zweitens
wenn es überhaupt weitere schritte geben
sollte über sondierungen hinaus laschet
ist natürlich geschwächt das heißt die
sorge lindners von damals die bügeln uns
unter die ist natürlich geringer aber
dann doch da und die letzte frage wie
ist steht sondern um die spd mit den
beiden also wie eng ist das verhältnis
von olaf scholz zu christian lindner
beispielsweise in diesem sinn nicht so
eng wie zwischen laschet und lindner
aber wir kennen alle christian lindner
das weiß man übrigens in der cdu auch
ganz genau mit ner ist dann pragmatiker
weiß dass es nicht sehr gut kenne und
wahrscheinlich bedrohlich für ihn würde
wenn er nochmal so etwas machte wie vor
vier jahren plötzlich abspringen aus
verhandlungen christian lindner ist
clever genug dann auch ein zusammengehen
mit der spd als großes projekt zu
verkaufen also das traue ich ihm
durchaus zu auch wenn sein verhältnis zu
scholz nicht so eng ist sie zu löschen
da ist es wieder dieses wort projekt was
gerhard baum schon geprägt hat eckart
lohse vielen dank ihr leiter der
parlamentsredaktion der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung vielen dank für die
hintergründe werden
und da sind meine damen und herren bei
der spd der wahlgewinnerin man vergisst
das ja manchmal in diesen tagen sie
sitzt fast ein bisschen unbeteiligt am
rand und beobachtet hat man zumindest
das gefühl das was da alles in diesen
tagen passiert aber am wochenende kommt
sie dann ja tatsächlich auch mal mit ins
spiel sonntag dann das treffen mit den
grünen und mit der fdp allerdings
einzeln also noch keine dreier
konstellation und noch gibt es auch
keinen termin für eine dreier
konstellation soll der nächste woche
irgendwann kommen es gibt eine neue
chance auf einen aufbruch hat carsten
schneider der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der
spd-bundestagsfraktion eben gerade im
ard morgenmagazin gesagt die frage ist
natürlich okay wo führt dieser aufbruch
hin es herrscht auf jeden fall gute
stimmung in der
laola für den neuen helden der
sozialdemokraten so euphorisch ist olaf
scholz in seiner karriere nicht oft
begrüßt worden auch parteichefin saskia
esken ordnet sich brav nachhinein der
neue starke mann wird akzeptiert erstmal
das kann natürlich zu schwierigen
situationen kommen wenn es jetzt um
kompromisse geht aber da haben wird es
letztlich nicht scheitern man weiß dass
das jetzt eine chance ist ein
sozialdemokratischen kanzler zu haben
insofern glaube ich schon dass die
disziplin die ja bemerkenswert hoch
gewesen ist in der vergangenheit auch in
der zukunft durchaus hoch bleiben wird
bei der traditionell streitlustigen spd
stellt sich allerdings immer gleich die
frage hält das auch oder ist die
harmonie nur fassade stillhalten auf dem
weg zur macht man kriegt uns auch nicht
auseinanderdividiert denn wir sind für
dasselbe politische programm angetreten
wir sind ja als spd angetreten und nicht
als einzelperson wir haben auch nicht
einfach behauptet geschlossen zu sein
sondern wir haben ja was dafür getan
nämlich unsere programmatischen
baustellen die haben wir abgearbeitet
der neue zusammenhalt harter arbeit der
wieder gewählte fraktionschef ebenfalls
ein parteilinker hat jedenfalls schon
mal die linie vorgegeben
es ist eine große aufgabe insbesondere
weil wir uns einig darüber sind so
schnell wie möglich olaf scholz zum
kanzler der bundesrepublik deutschland
zu wählen so viel harmonie und freudige
gesichter hat man jedenfalls bei der spd
lange nicht gesehen
so viele vorlagen an diesem vormittag
und um 10 uhr trifft sich dann ja auch
die neue grünen fraktion und
konstituiert sich im bundestag deswegen
passt doch gut dass unser kollege erhard
scherfer wie meistens ja schon so ein
bisschen vorher da ist schon gut morgen
erst
morgen also das was wir eben schon
gehört haben von gerhart baum und dann
auch eckart lohse doch mal die generelle
frage also wie positiv wie wie
barmherzig wollte ich fast sagen ist
denn da die stimmung im moment bei ihnen
auf der fraktionsebene in den letzten
tagen tatsächlich also
mit blick natürlich auch auf die
gespräche
das kommt darauf an mit wem man spricht
natürlich
wenn man sich hier bei den
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
umhört dann sind die bestens gelaunt wir
haben soeben in dem beitrag auch gesehen
auch gute stimmung bei der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen die sich ja
deutlich
vergrößert hat im vergleich zur letzten
legislaturperiode und so ein bisschen
vorsichtig und zurückhaltend ist man in
der unionsfraktion weil die lage so ist
wie sie jetzt auch hinreichend
beschrieben ist seit vergangenem sonntag
und dann auch an dem montag danach und
was sonst noch alles passiert ist auch
beispielsweise in der fraktionssitzung
hier und die linken muss man sagen sind
im moment ein kleines bisschen
abgetauchten finden mich so richtig
stadt haben auch am montag
beziehungsweise die zeitung ihre
statement abgesagt vor der
fraktionssitzung also
nicht ganz im reinen mit sich und schon
gar nicht mit dem ergebnis und auch bei
der afd die ja heute auch noch mal
zusammenkommt ist auch nicht alles gold
was glänzt sondern ganz im gegenteil da
brechen gleich zu beginn der
legislaturperiode
schon heftige auseinandersetzung auf
kommen wir vielleicht später noch drauf
also es ist schon eine ziemlich
gemischte gemengelagen und die fdp habe
ich vergessen in dieser reihenfolge
fällt mir gerade auf auch da insgesamt
gute stimmung zuversicht man hat ja
mehrere optionen nach wie vor
vermeintlich zumindest aber man ist im
rennen und hat auch mit dem
vielzitierten selbige zeigt dass man ein
machtfaktor sein will bei diesen
koalitionsverhandlungen und insofern wie
gesagt da die stimmung auch westens wird
und dass selbst habe eben auch schon mal
gesehen eher schärfer dann arbeiten wir
doch mal das ab was weder gestern im
laufe des tages auch gesehen haben
gucken uns mal die eine oder andere
stimme noch einmal kurz an sprechen über
die einzelnen parteien gerne nochmal
dezidiert und fangen wir an mit volker
wissing der sich ja gestern nachmittag
auf der fraktionsebene auch geäußert hat
christian lindner und ich haben gestern
mit annalena baerbock und robert habeck
ein erstes vertrauliches gespräch
geführt
und sind überein gekommen dass wir die
bilateralen gespräche in einer größeren
runde fortsetzen wollen dazu werden sich
bündnis 90 die grünen und die freien
demokraten am kommenden freitag treffen
dabei sollen erste inhaltliche fragen
vertieft werden
die unionsparteien haben die freien
demokraten zu einem gespräch eingeladen
dieses gesprächsangebot haben die freien
demokraten heute angenommen unser
angebot ist das gespräch am kommenden
samstag zu führen die union prüft das
noch
wie bereits öffentlich angekündigt haben
auch die sozialdemokraten uns gespräche
angeboten auch dieses gesprächsangebot
nehmen wir selbstverständlich an wir
haben vereinbart unsere kommenden
sonntag zu einem bilateralen austausch
zu treffen nach diesen gesprächen werden
wir unsere gremien darüber unterrichten
und sodann über den weiteren verlauf
beraten wenn sie es sagen sie treffen
sich in größerer runde am freitag können
sie beschreiben wie groß diese runde
sein wird von ihrer seite oder fanseiten
es wird ja sicher paritätisch besetzt
sein und welche inhaltlichen fragen wenn
sie das stichwort ist gesehen könnten
haben sie identifiziert über die jetzt
vertiefen der gesprächsbedarf besteht
die fdp wird mit den mitgliedern des
präsidiums an dieser fahrenschon an
diesen gesprächen teilnehmen und die
inhaltlichen fragen sind die die ihnen
bekannten fragen die auch im wahlkampf
eine zentrale rolle gespielt haben so
dass wir jetzt die dinge die wir
wahlkampf stark kommuniziert haben auch
auch
im hinblick auf eine mögliche
zusammenarbeit miteinander
prüfen und abklärung der sehe ich
sprachen davon sie haben wollen die
inhaltlichen fragen vertiefen das heißt
also mit anderen worten sie haben ja
über inhalte dann auch schon besprochen
und nicht nur das prozedere können sie
denn sagen welche themen da zumindest
mal angesprochen worden sind und zu den
künftigen gesprächen
werden wir davon was mitbekommen dass
sie sich treffen oder ist wieder geplant
gegessen haben und das dann irgendwie
selbst spät darum geschickt werden oder
wird es da halt ganz offiziell dann dazu
eingeladen so dass man halt auch davon
etwas mitbekommt im zweifel
wir haben alle
erfahrungen mit sondierungsgesprächen
und vor sondierungen und wir haben
daraus auch die notwendigen schlüsse
gezogen und es ist das besonders wichtig
dass die ersten gespräche in einem
vertrauensvollen und vertraulichen
rahmen geführt werden können das haben
wir gemeinsam sichergestellt und
deswegen kann ich ihnen über die inhalte
dieses gesprächs nichts berichten
wir haben uns dann aber entschieden weil
wir wissen dass es natürlich auch ein
großes öffentliches interesse daran gibt
dass wir ein bild sprechen lassen das
haben wir getan will aber auch dieses
bild jetzt nicht mit worten
interpretieren um die vertraulichkeit
der gespräche zu schützen herr und haben
nun endlich werden wir in zukunft wenn
wir zu entscheidungen kommen diese auch
öffentlich machen und werden diese
entscheidung dann auch inhaltlich
begründen
noch nicht klar ob sie am freitag dann
das in ähnlicher art und weise
organisieren im geheimen organisieren
werden und am samstag und am sonntag ob
das jetzt so intendiert ist dass sie
also tatsächlich hat unter ausschluss
der öffentlichkeit ohne bekanntgabe von
terminen und örtlichkeiten dann sich
zusammensetzen oder ob sie tatsächlich
dann auch das anders kommunizieren als
es gestern arm des geschehens wir
bereiten das gespräch am freitag
gegenwärtig vor und werden in den
nächsten tagen aufklären oder
kurzfristig klären wie wir das
öffentlich kommunizieren und
selbstverständlich wollen wir
die öffentlichkeit
nach möglichkeit beteiligen aber das
geht eben nur in dem rahmen in dem dinge
nicht vertraulich sein müssen
dann kommen wir zu herrn hofmann bitte
deswegen wenn sie sagen wir meinen sie
sicherlich die fdp das heißt sie fühlen
die gespräche mit union und spd
getrennt von den grünen oder führen sich
die zusammen erste frage und zweiter
frage in dem zusammenhang gibt es einen
grund für die reihenfolge oder wie ist
es dazu gekommen erst union dann spd
ja wir führen diese gespräche getrennt
weil wir das für erforderlich halten
dass wir zunächst einmal im rahmen
dieser vor sondierung bieter bilateral
miteinander sprechen es muss ja am ende
wenn man zu einem bündnis kommt jeder
mit jedem zusammenarbeiten wollen
deswegen ist das in bilateralen
gesprächen zunächst einmal vorab zu
klären und
die
reihenfolge
ergibt sich aus der situation wie die
terminlage sich darstellt es ist
natürlich jetzt nicht ganz einfach so
viele gespräche mit vielen personen in
kurzer zeit zu terminieren wir sind zu
dieser reihenfolge entsprechend gekommen
also dann erstmal zwei klarstellung zum
einen war das nicht in der
fraktionsebene sondern der
parteizentrale der fdp und andererseits
hat volker wissing hat sich eben schon
mal gesagt meine damen und herren ja
gestern klargestellt dass oftmals die
union am samstag nicht kann unabhängig
davon würde ich gerne schärfer nach nach
vorne schauen auf fdp und
grüne ist es für sie nachvollziehbar
dass die beiden sich mit der spd erst
einzeln am sonntag treffen und nicht
doch schon am sonntag beispielsweise
eben doch auch in der dreier
konstellation
ja das ist in vielfältiger weise
nachvollziehbar finde ich es hat ja
dieses modell das das möglicherweise
geben wird diese dreier konstellation je
nachdem wenn man cdu und sie ist so
tatsächlich immer als einheit versteht
hat das ja eine dreier konstellation in
dieser form zumindest die sie uns jetzt
mutmaßlich bevorsteht nicht gegeben und
da muss man die wege und natürlich auch
erst mal finden da muss man schauen wie
man sich in den verschiedenen bereichen
annähern kann grüne und fdp haben zwar
in vielen bereichen relativ große
gemeinsamkeiten aber sie haben halt in
anderen bereichen auch relativ große
unterschiede in den vorstellungen wie
man zu bestimmten politik zielen kommen
will nehmen wir das beispiel klimaschutz
da gibt es extrem unterschiedliche
modelle bei denen bei den grünen und
auch bei der fdp und da apple ab hört
mal zu gucken wie viel krieg ich denn
mit dem jeweiligen potenziellen
koalitionspartnern dem größeren durch
halte ich schon für durchaus sinnvoll um
sich da anzunähern also es ist
sicherlich auch ein prozess wie man eine
zu ergebnissen kommt den mann dem man
wie gesagt von dem es keine blaupause
gibt aus den vergangenen jahren und
jahrzehnten lassen sie mich eine kleine
anmerkung noch machen zu dem termin der
fdp mit der union das ist natürlich ein
bisschen kurios und sagt vielleicht zwar
noch nicht alles aber auch zumindest
viel über die lage in der union aus dass
man zwar der fdp und den grünen
gespräche anbietet dann aber am
wochenende keinen termin findet dass
zumindest der stand von heute morgen
noch keinen termin findet für die fdp
das ist schon ein bisschen kurios und da
wirst du ganz sicheren zustand
herauszufinden was dahintersteckte wer
da die treibende kraft ist und warum es
nicht gelingt im moment zumindest noch
nicht gelingt da zusammen zu kommen und
zu beraten absolut ersthelfer sind wir
sehr gespannt ob dieser tag heute
vielleicht ein bisschen erleuchtung
bringt und dann würde ich gerne gleich
nochmal auf das eingehen was sie eben
angesprochen haben nämlich die möglichen
gemeinsamkeiten oder nicht
gemeinsamkeiten zwischen grünen und fdp
aber dann macht er vielleicht sehen dass
wir auch nochmal auf annalena baerbock
hören die sich ja auch gestern geäußert
hat
23 tage nach der wahl wir leiten aus dem
wahlergebnis einen klaren auftrag ab
verantwortung für die zukunft unseres
landes zu übernehmen und eine
progressive regierung zu bilden das ist
nicht nur ein besonderer moment für
unsere partei sondern auch für dieses
land erstmalig für die drei parteien
gemeinsam gespräche über die zukunft und
auch über die erneuerung unseres landes
dafür haben wir jetzt alle weichen
entsprechend gestellt haben gestern
schon gemeinsam mit der fdp vertraulich
gesprochen werden dass am freitag dann
noch einmal in größerer runde fortsetzen
zwischen grünen und der fdp um dann am
samstag unseren eigenen kleinen
parteitag zu haben wo wir alle weiteren
schritte für diese sondierungsgespräche
und für die bildung einer möglichen
regierung in die wege zu leiten auch mit
blick auf weiteres sondierungsteam und
den neueren und weiteren zeitplan und
dann am sonntag gemeinsam mit der spd am
abend ebenfalls gespräche zu führen mit
der union stehen wir auch im kontakt
aber der auftrag den wir haben ist ein
klarer auftrag für eine erneuerung in
unserem land und in diesem sinne werden
wir auch in den nächsten tagen daran
arbeiten die grundlagen für eine
progressive regierung in deutschland zu
bilden nach sieben wochen intensiven
wahlkampf und jetzt der direkten
vorbereitung für die gespräche dafür
die neue regierung zu bilden und
verantwortung in diesem land zu
übernehmen ist der schlaf natürlich
nicht deutlich mehr geworden aber jetzt
sind die weichen dafür zu stellen
wirklich inhaltlich sich darauf zu
fokussieren wie wir eine nächste
regierung bilden können und wie ich ja
gerade deutlich gemacht habe sprechen
wir jetzt zuerst vor allem mit der fdp
und dann mit der spd da liegen
entsprechende nicht nur einladungen
sondern genau gesprächstermine ja auch
schon vor und die union hat uns heute
eingeladen auch zu gesprächen dann in
nächster woche und da muss man dann in
die genauere planung noch gehen 2017
sollte sich nicht wiederholen
deswegen ist unser anspruch wirklich
jetzt zügig gespräche zu führen und auch
vertrauensvoll gespräche zu führen
deswegen auch zum gestrigen abend oder
weitere gespräche ist unsere herzliche
einladung an alle anderen parteien aber
auch an uns dass es wirklich in
vertraulichkeit stattfindet weil die
weichen die man stellen will die sind ja
wirklich große erneuerung für dieses
land das heißt auch projekte die man an
geht die man bisher in diesem land noch
nicht angegangen ist gemeinsam
auszuloten und das braucht eine
vertraulichkeit aber es bedeutet auch
dass sich sondierung nicht über wochen
gar monate hinziehen können sondern dass
diese sanierung dann zügig vonstatten
gehen und wir haben bereits im wahlkampf
deutlich gemacht wir haben auch am
wahlabend deutlich gemacht nachdem klar
war dass die spd diese wahl gewonnen hat
dass wir zuerst gespräche mit spd und
fdp führen werden und vor allen dingen
dass wir den auftrag für eine
progressive regierung haben um dieses
land zu erneuern
aber dass wir natürlich mit allen
demokratischen parteien sprechen die spd
ist der wahlsieger nach dieser
bundestagswahl und deswegen ist es für
uns auch zentral diese gespräche jetzt
zu allererste zu führen aber wir reden
wie gesagt mit allen parteien und der
zweite punkt mit blick auf spd mit fdp
und grüne haben wir am wahlabend ja auch
schon deutlich gemacht dass wir zuerst
miteinander sprechen auch vertraulich
sprechen weil zum einen dieser auftrag
an uns ist dass wir eine wirkliche
erneuerung angehen und es mit blick auf
die fdp auch bereiche gibt wo man eben
eine erneuerung gerade im
gesellschaftspolitischen bereich
gemeinsam gestalten kann und auf der
anderen seite bekanntermaßen es themen
gibt wo man doch sehr weit auseinander
steht und eben auszuloten wo man brücken
bauen kann und wo man gemeinsam dieses
land ins nicht nur 21 jahrhundert
bringen kann sondern die weichen für die
zukunft zu stellen kann das halten wir
für sinnvoll und haben das am wahlabend
auch schon deutlich gemacht wir hatten
gestern ein gutes gespräch und wenn ich
jetzt drei sätze mehr sagen dann ist es
nicht mehr vertraulich deswegen dieses
gespräch bleibt vertraulich sowie andere
gespräche auch vertraulich bleiben
werden und wir werden aber und das ist
ja dann wenn die sondierung richtig
beginnen auch mit unserem parteitag
natürlich bei größeren gesprächen dann
entsprechend auch deutlich machen wer
daran teilnimmt waren diese gespräche
stattfinden wenn die gespräche dann wie
gesagt offiziell beginnen wir haben den
antragsentwurf für unseren parteitag
gerade eben auch versteckt wo unser
sondierungsteam mit zehn personen
benannt wird was dann bei größeren
runden entsprechend diese gespräche
führen wird so alles gestern sehr
procedural jetzt guck mal auf die
inhalte schärfer wer ich habe das ja bei
gerd baum schon eben bei uns im
tagesgespräch versucht er sagte auch es
gibt natürlich unterschiede aber der
druck sei so groß und die
gemeinsamkeiten die würden dann schon so
durch scheinig paraphrasieren das ganze
mal ist es aus ihrer sicht so dass die
unterschiede das klingt in diesen tagen
sogar nicht mehr so unüberwindbar sind
wie sie zumindest bis sonntag vor der
wahl noch klang
der unterschiede sind unterschiedlicher
ändert der wahltag erstmal nichts was
sich verändert hat oder was sich auch
weiter verändern wird ist natürlich die
rhetorik oder das betrachten der
jeweiligen inhalte aber wie ich eben
schon mal gesagt habe es gibt ja schon
sehr deutlich und sehr deutlich
wahrnehmbare differenzen zwischen grünen
und
fdp und das beispiel was ich eben gesagt
habe beispielsweise beim klimaschutz
beim umweltschutz und allem was
dazugehört da ist es halt ganz besonders
augenfällig und da wird es auch
wahrscheinlich sehr harte und sehr
schwierige verhandlungen geben ganz dem
anlass anderen oder ganz im gegensatz zu
befragen wie finanzen und haushalt dass
sie eigentlich sind bereiche wie lassen
sich da lassen sich differenzen
überwinden auch da gibt es ja im
wahlkampf deutlich zur schau getragene
unterschiede in dem auf der einen seite
die grünen sich ja ausgesprochen haben
für höhere steuern insbesondere für
spitzenverdiener und die fdp gesagt hat
was sie eines nicht passieren darf dann
sind das höhere steuern weder für
bürgerinnen und bürger noch für
unternehmen also da hat man das ganze
sogar als rote linie definiert da wird
es sicherlich möglichkeiten geben
zusammenzukommen um beide seiten zu
befriedigen und auch bei die klientel
beider seiten zufrieden zu stellen aber
wie gesagt gerade klimaschutz halte ich
wirklich für ein ganz schwieriges feld
weil die grünen da sehr dezidierte
vorstellungen haben es soll ja auch
möglichst schnell was passieren beim
klimaschutz soll möglichst schnell
nachvollziehbar sein was mit der politik
erreicht worden ist in der kommenden
legislaturperiode wohingegen ja auch
zwar die fdp auch sagt dass sie sich für
den klimaschutz einsetzt aber gänzlich
andere wege dafür vorsieht
beispielsweise auf technischen
fortschritt setzt und auf eine
wasserstoff technologie die in diesem
umfang im moment noch gar nicht da ist
da zusammen zu kommen das wir glaube ich
in relativ hart werden und wie gesagt
vor diesem hintergrund sieht diese
vorgespräche gar nicht mal so sinnlos da
würde ich gleich gern noch mal mit ihnen
darüber sprechen welche rolle dann im
zweifel auch der spd zukommt gucken wir
doch da in diesem zusammenhang dann
gerne mal als vorlage auf lars klingbeil
den
generalsekretär der spd gestern
wir sind jetzt dabei nach der wahl uns
zu sortieren heute haben wir rolf
mützenich mit einem überragenden
ergebnis zum fraktionsvorsitzenden
gewählt hat das große vertrauen bekommen
gestern eine wirklich tolle auch
emotionale fraktionssitzung in der 104
neue kolleginnen und kollegen mit sehr
bewegenden geschichten sich vorgestellt
haben also alle waren glaube ich sehr
stolz auf das was wir in den letzten
wochen auch durch diesen fulminanten
sieg bei der wahl dann erreicht haben
diese aufholjagd die da war die alle
auch nochmal bestärkt hat und das merkt
in der spd fraktion
wir haben am montag im präsidium im
parteivorstand einstimmig jeweils gesagt
wir wollen jetzt gespräche führen mit
den grünen mit der fdp und wollen jetzt
sehr zügig zu einer stabilen regierung
kommen haben wir haben in den letzten
tagen mit den generalsekretären
vertrauensvoll über diese frage auch
geredet sie haben alle mitbekommen dass
der zeitplan jetzt steht wir werden uns
am sonntagnachmittag mit der fdp treffen
am sonntagabend dann mit den grünen und
werden in gesprächen für einsteigen mit
dem festen willen von unserer seite dann
eine regierung zu bilden die künftige
regierung das würde ich ja auch sagen
hat drei große aufgaben die erledigt
werden müssen das eine ist ja wir müssen
so aufgestellt sein dass wir die großen
zukunftsaufgaben dieses landes anpacken
können geht um klimaschutz es geht um
digitalisierung staatsmodernisierung es
muss eine regierung sein die europa
wieder stärker in den mittelpunkt rückt
es muss eine regierung sein die zweitens
eine andere art des politikmachens auch
definiert also eine regierung in der es
nicht um gewinner und verlierer geht
sondern wo stabil unter
koalitionspartnern zusammengearbeitet
wird die schwarz gelbe regierung 2009
bis 2013 ist das abschreckende beispiel
genauso was wollen wir nicht sondern ein
vertrauensvolles verhältnis zwischen den
akteuren dieser regierung und die dritte
aufgabe die eine künftige regierung zu
leisten hat ist eine junge generation
wirklich auch für politik zu gewinnen
haben die themen anzupacken die für eine
junge generation wichtig sind am und
anzugehen dass das vertrauen einer
jungen generation in politik wächst wir
haben unsere verhandlungsgruppe ja
genannt das ist der kanzlerkandidat olaf
scholz die beiden parteivorsitzenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden malu dreyer für
die länder und das bin ich als
generalsekretär und von den anderen
parteien werden dann jeweils auch
delegation da sein das ziel ist jetzt am
sonntag in gespräche einzusteigen ich
habe gerade benannt was für uns wichtig
ist die frage der großen
herausforderungen gibt es dafür ein
gemeinsames verständnis natürlich wird
man auch darüber reden wo sind
knackpunkte das ist ja offensichtlich
dass wir nicht alle mit den gleichen
inhalten auch in den wahlkampf gegangen
sind und dann wird man danach auswerten
wie dieses gespräch gelaufen ist es gibt
drei parteien die die wahl gewonnen
haben drei parteien wo der balken nach
oben geht unser festes ziel ist eine
koalition der gewinner zu schmieden und
dafür zu sorgen dass diese koalition der
gewinner auch die großen
herausforderungen des landes anpacken
kann und was die konkreten gespräche am
sonntag angeht bitte ich um verständnis
dass wir unter den generalsekretären
gesagt haben wir machen jetzt den
zeitplan öffentlich wir kommen dann am
sonntag zusammen aber genaue uhrzeiten
länge des gespräches das wird sich jetzt
auf der strecke geben wir haben die
einladung montag ausgesprochen aber das
waren jetzt einfach gespräche unter den
generalsekretären die er seit wochen
schon vertrauensvoll sind sie wissen
dass wir einen vernünftigen draht haben
also das ist jetzt nicht so dass sie
einen gesagt haben wir laden euch ein
und die anderen danach denken mussten
ist es so dass wir einfach jetzt auf der
strecke entschieden haben wir treffen
uns dann sollte wir haben am montag klar
gemacht einstimmig in beiden gremien wir
wollen mit grünen und der fdp reden das
ist jetzt der wille den wir als spd
haben und da gibt es gerade keinen plan
b es ist doch wichtig bei den aufgaben
die ich gerade beschrieben habe das ist
kein vertrauensvolles miteinander gibt
und da ist doch gut wenn jetzt gerade
gespräche stattfinden wenn dinge geklärt
werden wenn dinge auf den weg gebracht
werden und das wird jetzt eine ganze
reihenfolge von gesprächen geben noch
mal wichtig ist wer am ende den
koalitionsvertrag unterschreibt und da
bin ich sehr optimistisch dass das am
ende die parteien sein werden die auch
den auftrag der wählerinnen und wähler
bekommen haben also die drei wo der
balken am sonntag nach oben gegangen ist
er hat ja mal ganz offen gefragt welche
rolle kommt jetzt der spd zu in diesen
drei in dieser dreier konstellation vor
allem nachdem sich grüne und fdp ja dann
mindestens schon zweimal miteinander
getroffen haben werden bevor sie dann
gemeinsam die spd treffen wenn
eine moderierende auf der einen seite
wird es sein müssen die olaf scholz aber
auch die beiden parteivorsitzenden und
alle anderen die an diesem vor
sondierungsgesprächen teilnehmen
einnehmen müssen auf der anderen seite
kennen wir alle den satz von olaf scholz
wehrführung besteht der bekommt auch
welche und es ist so dass alle die in
diesem prozess beteiligt sind den
kanzlerkandidaten der spd da durchaus
mit großem respekt begegnen weil sie
wissen dass er sehr sehr hart verhandeln
kann
wenn es um bestimmte dinge geht und
diese erfahrung haben die grünen auch
schon in dem einen unter anderem
zusammenhang gemacht beispiel hamburg
als olaf scholz der bürgermeister erster
bürgermeister in hamburg war um mit den
grünen koaliert hat haben die grünen
längst nicht alles bekommen was sie
gerne gehabt hätten also also ist auch
da durchaus in der lage sich
durchzusetzen und deswegen wird es eine
spannende aufgabe werden für olaf scholz
diese beiden sehr unterschiedlichen in
manchen bereichen sehr unterschiedlichen
parteien auf der einen seite zusammen zu
bringen aber das auch noch auf einer
ebene und einer möglichkeit die auch
noch der sozial punkte der
sozialdemokratischen politik raum lassen
raum lässt insbesondere in der
sozialpolitik der kommt der händler
daher insbesondere in der sozialpolitik
da gibt es ja auch zwischen fdp und
grünen durchaus unterschiede also auch
da muss ein mittelweg gefunden werden
und wenn man das ganze dann
zusammenbindet und im ganzen beguckt
also dieses gesamte dieses gesamte
koalition die es einmal werden soll
falls es die wird nämlich diese ampel
koalition dann muss es ja auch noch die
gelegenheit geben das auf der einen
seite alles zusammen funktioniert das
also ein gemeinsames ziel alle drei ein
gemeinsames ziel vor augen haben aber
gleichzeitig alle drei ihre positionen
deutlich machen können also alle drei
auch zu möglichen gewinnern gehören in
einer solchen koalition und das wird
richtig harte arbeit werden in den
kommenden wochen wenn es wie gesagt auf
eine solche ampel koalition hinausläuft
ist wäre allerdings auch nicht viel
leichter in einer jamaika-koalition von
der wir uns glaube ich im moment ein
kleines stück gedanklich verabschieden
können ein weiteres indiz war meiner
meinung nach heute morgen eine
interviewäußerung äußerung von katrin
göring eckardt die gesagt hat sie sehe
eine jamaika koalition in dieser
legislaturperiode nicht mehr warum ist
das interessant das ist deshalb
interessant weil katrin göring-eckardt
in einer jamaika koalition durchaus gute
chancen gehabt haben könnte
bundespräsidentin zu werden wenn sie
jetzt schon sagt diese variante diese
call dieses koalitionsmodells hält sie
für unwahrscheinlich und für wenig
realistisch und auch für wenig
zielführend dann deutet doch vieles auch
wenn man die äußerung beispielsweise von
annalena baerbock gestern noch dazu
kommt nimmt und die vieler anderer
vieles darauf hin dass bei den grünen
inzwischen sehr sehr deutlich eine ampel
favorisiert wird sehr spannend schärfer
und dann lassen sie uns zum abschluss
gleich nochmal über die afg sprechen und
meine damen und herren das war gestern
abend ja dann doch ein sehr sehr
interessantes prozedere was da bei der
afg vor sich gegangen ist also gestern
die konstituierende sitzung der neuen
afg bundestagsfraktion aber eigentlich
wollte man ja die neue fraktionsspitze
wählen dazu kam es nicht das ist jetzt
auf den heutigen tag verschoben weil die
gestrige sitzung als sehr sehr stürmisch
bezeichnet wurde es ging offenbar hoch
her und es ging um mehrere dinge zwei
abgeordnete der afd war lange nicht klar
sollen die jetzt teil der fraktions will
werden oder nicht es ging wohl so heftig
dass teilweise mitarbeiter der fraktion
raus geschickt wurden und es ging auch
um das führungsduo der afg im
bundestagswahlkampf die jetzt sich als
du für die fraktionsspitze gemeldet
hatten
es ist angerichtet der empfang zur
ersten fraktionssitzung die botschaft
nach außen seht her wir haben uns
eingerichtet sind eine stabile größe im
parlament doch es ist dann wie so oft
bei der afg ist liegt schon beim empfang
da in der luft ein grund ist er matthias
helferich neu im bundestag aber bereits
in der afg mit amp der sperre belegt
wegen chats mit ns bezügen naja muss ja
aussagen getroffen haben wir definitiv
nicht zur partei und fraktion passen und
was will ich eigentlich nicht haben weil
das etwas ist was nicht passt es ist die
alte frage in der afc was geht noch und
was ist dann doch selbst für die afg zu
radikal einige abgeordnete die dem
rechtsextremen lager zugeordnet werden
sind ausgeschieden dafür rücken neue
nach auch eine enge vertraute von bernd
höcker ich bin mit björn fecker
befreundet wie schätze ihn als mensch
und ich schätze auch seine politische
arbeit
ist der einzige also der vorsitzende des
einzigen landesverbandes der ja dazu
gewonnen hat bei den wahlen die
politische arbeit des rechtsextremisten
heute als vorbild für die bundes fdp
mindestgrenze sich auch das wahlkampf
spitzenduo weidl und krupp aller nicht
vom hocker ab apropos auch hier streit
im anmarsch die beiden wollen sich als
fraktionsvorsitzenden wählen lassen doch
nicht alle sind vom auftreten von weide
begeistert auch deshalb sinn mancher
keine doppelspitze mehr sollte um so
sein dass man einzeln und separat wählen
kann ich meine persönliche meinung die
meinung der fraktion wenn man sehen die
fraktion setzt dann überraschend erst
mal ein anderes thema auf die
tagesordnung soll matthias hell bericht
der fraktion angehören die sitzung ist
drei stunden alt als der wortlos die
sitzung verlässt erklärung des
parlamentarischen geschäftsführers
das ist sehr kritisch diskutiert worden
und dann hat herr helferich von sich
selbst
geäußert dass er nicht mitglied der
fraktion werden will und das ist so
akzeptiert worden es folgt die nächste
diskussion über den wahlausgang nicht
alle sehen den so rosig wie die
fraktionsspitze die wahl zum neuen
fraktionsvorsitz wird übrigens dann
erstmal auf morgen verschoben neue
fraktion aber in puncto drama alles wie
immer bei der afd
also erschafft drama
stürmische sitzung können sie uns das
ganze nochmal einordnen was wir gestern
abend bei der afg erlebt haben
ja im wesentlichen ist es ja im beitrag
angeklungen dass es doch intensive
diskussion gibt über die strategie
dieses wahlkampfs und das haben wir auch
am montag schon gesehen in der
pressekonferenz mit parteichef jörg
merten auf der einen seite und den
beiden spitzenkandidaten kino kubala und
alice weiter auf der anderen seite dass
man sehr unterschiedlich interpretiert
hat diesen wahlausgang bei dem die
hälfte ja knapp 2 etwas mehr als zwei
prozent verloren hat im vergleich 2
prozentpunkte verloren hat im vergleich
zu 20 17 damit auch vier mandate
verloren hat im vergleich zu 20 17
zumindest zum beginn der
legislaturperiode sind ja dann im laufe
der vergangenen vier jahre doch noch ein
paar weniger geworden durch austritt aus
der partei und deswegen verknüpft ja
wenn man so will die fraktion auch an
dieser stelle wieder an unruhe an die es
in der partei gibt es gibt intensive
diskussionen darüber ob ihre tino kruppa
und alice weide tatsächlich als duo
gewählt werden sollen das ist nicht
ausgemacht es wird jetzt spannend werden
wie das heute ab 14 uhr wenn ihr die kfd
wieder zusammenkommt im plenarsaal wie
das ganze ausgeht wird auch wiederum ein
zeichen dafür sein wie wieviel ja
wieviel disput da ist und was das
wiederum bedeutet für die kommende
legislaturperiode die zwei um die es
geht sind in dem beitrag ja eben
angeklungen der eine hat sich in einem
chat als das freundliche gesicht des ns
bezeichnet und wird jetzt wie gesagt
dieser fraktion nicht angehören ob er
einen gaststatus beantragt scheint noch
offen zu sein und die die fraktion
umgehen will mit dem abgeordneten
moosdorf aus sachsen der von einigen
abgeordneten als querulant bezeichnet
wird und der auch alexander gauland
mehrfach sehr heftig kritisiert hat das
wird man dann noch sehen müssen also für
eine ruhige parlamentsarbeit in ruhigen
fahrwassern oder danach sieht es im
moment nicht aus das wollte ich sie
gerade fragen schärfer zum abschluss
doch gerne noch mal nicht man die fdlr
ist vier jahre im bundestag
trotzdem hat man das gefühl sie ist so
zerstritten wie man das wie man das sich
kaum vorstellen konnte die
pressekonferenz am montag haben wir hier
live übertragen da konnte man sich das
ja wirklich eins zu eins an schauen
jetzt hat die fraktion 25 neue afg
abgeordnete sie haben selbst gesagt ist
unklar wieder die wahl heute nachmittag
ausfällt was heißt das denn für die
arbeit dieser fraktion in den nächsten
vier jahren
ich vermute mal dass ich an der arbeit
der fraktion in da nicht sehr viel
ändern wird kritiker der afg fraktion im
deutschen bundestag sagen ja dass die
abgeordneten der afg in plenums reden
relativ laute und provokante reden
halten das camp auch das kennen wir auch
von unseren übertragungen es ist dann
regelmäßig im plenum auch große unruhe
mit zwischenrufen
unterschiedlichster art die gelegentlich
auch gerückt werden müssen durch das
bundestagspräsidium das ist das was man
kennt und das was man sieht von der afg
im deutschen bundestag viele abgeordnete
aus den anderen fraktionen mit denen man
spricht sagen das spiegele sich nicht
wieder in den sitzungen der ausschüsse
der fachausschüsse die hier tagen und
beraten die sich mit anträgen und mit
gesetzentwürfen auseinandersetzen da sei
die afd nach anfänglichem interesse in
den besitzungen nicht sonderlich präsent
gewesen ich zitiere da nur die anderen
abgeordneten das hat dann auch immer
wieder heftige auseinandersetzungen
gegeben auch im plenum über anträge und
gesetzentwürfe die afg vorgelegt hat von
denen viele abgeordnete sagen sie seien
nicht auf dem stand der dinge oder sie
seien in sich nicht schlüssig das ist
also auch ein großer teil der
parlamentsarbeit man hatte bisweilen den
eindruck zumindest dass das der fc im
großen und ganzen egal ist entscheidend
ist für die afd dass sie hier reden hält
im plenum die sie dann beispielsweise
für ihre sozialen medien raus klippen
die sie dann online stellen die sie
posten bei youtube beispielsweise
selbstverständlich ohne gegenrede die
ihn dazu folgen und die dann in der tat
ein hohes abruf potenzial haben und die
dann das eigene klientel quasi
bestätigen indem und in der meinung die
man von der afg hat und das ist halt
jetzt das zentrale anliegen muss man
sagen politische arbeit aus sicht der
fdp findet hier im kleinen im stadt und
da sind dass sie die einzelnen reden
egal wer davor oder dahinter geredet hat
und egal wie die argumente der anderen
jeweils sind sehr spannend finanzämter
für diese ganzen einordnungen auch so
von hinter den kulissen wir warten ja
eigentlich auch die konstituierende
sitzung der grünen bundestagsfraktion
aber da wird's wenn ich das richtig eben
gehört habe vorher keine statements
geben
nein das ist relativ unwahrscheinlich
dass hat unter anderem auch damit zu tun
dass hier große entscheidungen nicht
anstehen bei der heutigen sitzung die um
10 uhr beginnen soll im plenarsaal
übrigens deswegen sieht man hinter mir
relativ wenig sonst würde man ja sagen
wo sind wir denn eigentlich alle es hat
hier vorhin ein kleines fotoshooting
gegeben mit neun abgeordneten haben wir
unter anderem den früheren
verdi-vorsitzende maske gesehen der
jetzt auch zur grünen fraktion gehört
mein die fraktion wird sich heute eine
vorläufige geschäftsordnung wiedergeben
beziehungsweise die bekannte
geschäftsordnung dann verabschieden dass
es der rechtliche rahmen für die arbeit
der fraktionen in den kommenden wochen
und dann wird man beschließen dass alle
die im moment in amt und würden sind
also die beiden fraktionsvorsitzenden
aber auch der gesamte fraktionsvorstand
kommissarisch weiter arbeiten wird bis
auf weiteres bis auf weiteres ist das
ist relativ normal in solchen phasen
insbesondere wenn eine fraktion und
partei in der regierungsbildung noch
beteiligt sind man weiß ja nicht wie das
ganze ausgeht man weiß nicht welche
ämter dann wohin vergeben werden wer
möglicherweise aus dem fraktionsvorstand
von den beiden fraktionsvorsitzenden
aufrückt in andere ämter die dann
natürlich da muss entsprechend
nachbesetzt werden insofern arbeitet man
in den strukturen weiter die man sich
vor über zuletzt gegeben hat hat erstmal
damit ruhe und ein system in der arbeit
und alles weitere findet sich dann es
wird auch diskutiert letzter satz auch
diskutiert werden natürlich über das
ergebnis nochmal und über die sondierung
und den fahrplan für die kommenden
wochen er hat vielen dank und sie sind
ja vor ort und für uns da und wir sind
hier zeit wieder bei ihnen wenn da was
passiert vielen dank schon mal für die
ganzen 1 zur einordnung hier am morgen
so meine damen und herren und da sind
wir doch weiter innerhalb dieser stunde
hier bei phoenix vor ort und wohl gern
noch weiter darüber sprechen diskutieren
professor volker kronenberg
politikwissenschaft der universität bonn
ist hier der professor kronberg schauen
wir erstmal ganz mit dem überbau an nach
all dem was wir auch schon dieser stunde
diskutiert haben gehört haben ist sehr
extrem spannende tage für
politikjournalisten wir uns für die
öffentlichkeit für sie als professor der
politikwissenschaft nämlich mal noch ja
absolut das dass es spannend warum weil
natürlich hier
besonderheiten tatsächlich jetzt ihre
wirkung zeigen die wir natürlich schon
vorher kannten das keine amtierende
kanzlerin mehr antritt und und da gibt
es natürlich einiges was wir im vorfeld
schon wussten und dann aber jetzt ist es
natürlich sehr spannend was macht man
aus dieser neuen konstellation und ein
ganz spannendes momentum erleben wir ja
schon das ist jetzt nicht das zwischen
der erstplatzierten partei und der
zweitplatzierten 15 prozent sind nein
interessant ist ja dass die ersten
gespräche sozusagen mit den sogenannten
kleineren
stattgefunden haben das ist ein novum
und wie damit umgegangen wird wie
selbstbewusst eben hier auch grüne und
fdp hier agieren das heft des handelns
in die hand nehmen damit natürlich ja
auch schon eine tonalität setzen und
signale aussenden das ist das eine und
das andere ist natürlich auch herr bauer
in aller kürze das wahlverhalten die
junge generation die eben gelb und grün
sehr stark gewählt haben natürlich auch
der absturz der union und die frage wie
kam es zum schluss der spd darüber
sollten wir sprechen vor allem über die
kleinen über grünen und fdp und auch die
frage wie ist eigentlich das potenzial
der jungen hier und welche rolle spielt
das weggucken nochmal auf die frage
eigentlich wir sind eigentlich
tatsächlich die inhaltlichen
gemeinsamkeiten und unterschiede
zwischen grünen und fdp
betrachtet man die wahlprogramme von
grünen und fdp so lassen sie sich
scheinbar leicht zu einem gesamtbild
zusammenfügen auf den zweiten blick wird
es komplizierter thema klima die grünen
wollen tempolimit 130 den kohleausstieg
auf 20 30 vorziehen und ab dann nur noch
komplett emissionsfreie autos zu lassen
die fdp möchte kein tempolimit
kohleausstieg bei 20 38 erstmal belassen
und auf die innovationskraft der
autoindustrie vertrauen ein kompromiss
thema könnte der emissionshandel sein
auf denen setzt die fdp als instrument
des marktes und den grünen könnte es die
chance bieten durch teure zertifikate
den co2 preis zu erhöhen gut fürs klima
auch zwischen den parteien thema geld
die fdp will auf keinen fall die
schuldenbremse aufweichen und auch nicht
die steuern erhöhen die grünen wollen
geld für klimaschutz investitionen und
die steuern für kleinere und mittlere
einkommen senken für größere einkommen
und vermögen anheben hier ist ein
kompromiss schwierig möglich sind aber
wohl klima investitionen die über
sonderwege finanziert werden also nicht
gegen die schuldenbremse verstoßen und
dann noch das thema gesundheit hier
wollen die grünen eine
bürgerversicherung für alle einführen
die fdp am bestehenden system von
privaten und gesetzlichen kassen
festhalten einigung in diesem punkt wohl
schwierig
als bürgerliche parteien gibt es
allerdings auch gemeinsames bei den
bürgerrechten der gleichberechtigung der
digitalen bildung dem datenschutz der
integration den wählerschichten und
wahrscheinlich auch dem wunsch bald
endlich wieder zu regieren
ja dieser regierung der steht vielleicht
über allem professor kronberg aber jetzt
mal auf die inhalte geguckt dieser
beitrag geben wir eine schöne vorlage
für uns wie soll das denn gehen ich habe
das in dieser stunde eben schon mal
gefragt ich finde aber trotzdem da kann
man noch mal ein bisschen tiefer bohren
und hoffe sie sind damit noch mehr
antworten mit am start also wie soll das
gehen die einen sagen passt mal auf
dieses system der krankenversicherung
gkv gesetzliche krankenversicherung pkv
private das ist doch völlig
unsolidarisch ja wir brauchen ein system
wo alle gleichzeitig rein zahlen und
damit haben wir auch viel mehr masse und
geld vorhanden für alle und es zieht sie
nicht raus die anderen sagen nein nein
wir wollen dieses ich sage es mal etwas
elitäres system die besseren können es
sich leisten die private zu gehen sonst
die breite masse in der gkv das wollen
wir uns bei behalten wie soll das denn
zusammen kommen aber sie sprechen
natürlich einen ganz sensiblen und ganz
wichtigen punkt an aber das ist eine
ständig ssten bretter und ich wage sehr
zu bezweifeln dass man genau da
natürlich jetzt anfängt zu bohren ja
weil natürlich das ist jetzt eine
mammut-aufgabe wenn sie an sozialen
sicherungssystemen agieren reformieren
dann ist das gute und sinnvolle
tradition dass man da natürlich weit
über über regierung ob wir sie zu uns
grenzen hinweg versucht so viel wie
möglich ins boot zu holen ob das jetzt
gerade das stadtprojekt von rot und grün
sein wird wage ich zu bezweifeln die
antwort lautet natürlich nein sondern
der besuch wir suchen im die die felder
wo man näher beieinander als und die
gibt es ja dass deswegen bei der beitrag
sehr schön was ist das es natürlich
digitalisierung runtergebrochen auch im
bereich beispielsweise von schule
bildungspolitik von wissenschaft also
die
beispielsweise die die nutzung von von
von von elektronischen geräten im
unterricht und anderes mehr das sind ja
alles dinge die die jungen wählerinnen
und wähler angesprochen haben und b wie
diese beiden parteien ja unabhängig
voneinander schon lange folk oder immer
wieder intoniert und gefordert haben ja
schule bildungspolitik muss reformiert
werden wir müssen wie gesagt die
digitalisierung anderes mehr so dass da
ist natürlich durch corona noch eine
ganz neue dringlichkeit hinzu kommt das
ist eine brücke andere bereich
gesellschaftspolitik liberalisierung bis
hin zum beispiel hans in teilen
drogenpolitik ganz wichtig da sind
nennen da überhaupt liberale
gesellschaftspolitik und dann wird man
das da ist nähe da uns ja auch beim
klima grundsätzlich da muss man dann
genauer gucken frage wie wird finanziert
die frage wie wird es finanziert und da
ist man natürlich auch und da kommen
dann natürlich die schwierigen bereichen
gilt aber die stellt wenn ich an ihn
anfangen am anfang geht es ja darum
brücken zu finden und das war ja auch
der sub text von diesem self ii also wir
haben schon drücken erkannt schwieriger
wird es dann die sie sagen dann geht es
um steuern dann geht es eben um finanz
dann geht es um vermögenssteuer steuern
rauf oder runter spitzensteuersatz aber
das kommt am ende da wird man
kompromisse finden übrigens auch wie bei
der frage sie haben da wird man
kompromisse aber selbstverständlich wie
beim thema tempolimit die einen sagen na
in die anderen sagen ja 130
das sind weil man ist erfahren und sie
haben eben den satz gesagt man möchte
regieren man muss es nicht aber man will
es man hat die erfahrung von 217 da sind
sondierungen zwischen gelb und grün
gescheitert das heißt aber jetzt nicht
wir stehen unter druck wir müssen aber
beide wollen natürlich auch wenn sie von
pfarrer aus dem unterschiedlichen
spektrum kommen aber hier sind profis am
werk und wir haben eben des eingangs der
eingangstore
es sind neue zeiten ist es eine
fordernde konstellation das ist eine
chance für die beiden kleineren und alle
erkennen ja nach 16 jahren merkel es
muss nach vorne gehen es muss sich was
tun reform es angesagt und das kann ein
interpret aktiv sein um wie gesagt so
die ersten brücken zu beschreiten ok und
dann gucken wir auf die brücken
kronberg zusammen auch mit der spd
carsten schneider meine damen und herren
der parlamentarische geschäftsführer der
spd bundestagsfraktion heute morgen im
ard morgenmagazin und hatte das hier
gesagt
also diese fraktion ist ein jungbrunnen
für die spd aber auch für den deutschen
bundestag ist sehr divers sehr viele
frauen sehr viele junge leute viele mit
migrationshintergrund über 17 ist
absoluter gewinn und viele von ihnen
über die hälfte sind direkt gewählt da
sie haben direkt das mandat des volkes
und haben eine ganz klare aufgabe und
auftrag das ist olaf scholz uhr
bundeskanzler zu machen eine solide
regierung zu bilden und den sozialen
zusammenhalt mit fortschritt zu
verbinden also ich will auch dass wir
einen starken sozialstaat haben gerade
als antwort auch auf die krisen die wir
hatten sowohl köhler als auch die
finanzkrise die gezeigt hat man braucht
den aktivierenden start wir haben es
gibt eine sehr lange sozial-liberale
traditionen sind auch eine sehr alte
partei wie die spd auch und ich glaube
man das kann durchaus gut sein sich
gegenseitig zu befruchten wir die besten
das beste aus aller welt zusammen packt
und das wollen wir in vertraulichen
gesprächen tun und ich bin durchaus
zuversichtlich dass es auch sehr schnell
gelingen kann über eine gemeinsame
regierung bilden auch eine gemeinsame
hier nicht fraktionsgemeinschaft eine
gemeinsame zusammenarbeit im deutschen
bundestag viele punkte gingen was zur
liberalisierung des landes betrifft ich
denke auch zum beispiel an das wahlrecht
ging mit der cdu/csu nicht weil sie
einfach ihre besitzstände wahren wollten
das gibt jetzt die chance für einen
neuen aufbruch und das wenn sich ich sag
mal liberale und grüne gut verstehen
finde ich das prima wir wollen auch eine
koalition auf augenhöhe und nicht
das dadurch dass wir größer sind
irgendwie anders mit ihnen umgeben
gegenteil alle sind gleich gewährte und
das wird sich dann auch in den
koalitionsverhandlungen die natürlich
auch vertrauensbildende maßnahmen sind
auch april im endeffekt entscheiden dass
die jeweiligen fraktionen wenn sie
bundeskanzler machen mit dem sich stabil
regieren wollen ich kann beiden
fraktionen parteien nach nur an
empfehlen aufs volk zu hören wollen oder
volks- und er ist auch der besseren
übrigen auf die spd kann man sich
verlassen wir hatten hier in den
vergangenen jahren schwieriger zeit der
spd immer meine aufgabe konnte ich mich
auf meine fraktion verlassen wir hatten
ein zwei gegenstimmen währenddessen die
cdu/csu-fraktion bis zu 20 30
gegenstimmen bei corona gesetzt aber
vielen anderen letzten der letzten
legislatur hat und wenn man sieht wie
sie sich jetzt zerlegen csu vor allem
gegen cdu kann ich nur sagen das wäre
keine stabile regierung und ich vermute
mal dass ich das auch bei den anderen
parteien fraktionen rumgesprochen hat
herr professor kronberg sie haben gesagt
die müssen sich nicht einigen eben
gerade aber wenn sie sich nicht einigen
würden dann bliebe ja wieder nur die
große koalition die doch eigentlich
niemand in irgendeiner form im blick hat
also müssen sie sich doch einigen der
druck ist doch massiv
der druck ist massiv das ist richtig
aber es gibt jetzt sozusagen kein kein
automatismus es geht ja darum
letztendlich dass ein gesamtpaket auf
das ist ja an komfort wie eben über
einzel felder sprachen es geht ja dann
nachher auch so und gesamten narrativ um
eine idee eines reformbündnis ob das
eine ampel oder jamaika was auch immer
und das ganze muss ja dann auch intern
die grünen signalisieren da ist ja schon
grad die grüne jugend sagt dass er schon
als zweifelsfall müssen die mitglieder
befragt werden dann kommt kühn hat
natürlich auch damit der mitglieder das
heißt es muss am ende natürlich auch
legitim er war sein nach innen also
insofern geht man jetzt in diese
gespräche natürlich mit einer
erwartungshaltung da haben sie recht
aber es muss nicht sein übrigens ja
interessant einen tag nach der wahl die
befragungen in der bevölkerung welches
bündnis würden sie favorisieren dann
immer noch die so genannte große
koalition damit will ich nicht sagen
dass es dazu kommt oder wünschenswert
wäre ich sehe aber wir haben sie eben
nur antippen können ich sehe ja durchaus
wir haben von brücken gesprochen es gibt
ja bereiche die man identifizieren kann
und wo man was machen kann und außerdem
würde ich auch sagen dann gerade herrn
steiner gehört und das sind andere herr
scholz steht da an der spitze sozusagen
exemplarisch die tonalität der umgang
miteinander ist er jetzt schon
auffallend moderat und sozusagen
aufeinander zubewegen das sind glaube
ich ganz gute voraussetzungen gut also
dass die tonalität doch mal zum
abschluss hier die frage die großen
themen die viele auch kritisiert haben
dass sie eigentlich im wahlkampf zu
wenig vorkam also brauchen wir nicht
eine große steuerreform brauchen wir
eine reform der
krankenversicherungssysteme brauchen wir
nicht vielleicht eine reform des
rentensystems im sinne von die rente mit
70 rente mit vielleicht 73 65 all das
wurde ja in großen teilen im wahlkampf
wenig diskutiert wann kommen diese
themen eigentlich aus ihrer sicht mal
aufs tableau wenn sie jetzt auch wieder
sagen es gibt viele gemeinsamkeiten bei
anderen themen aber bei diesen großen
gibt es eben große unterschiede
ich erwarte nicht wenn es einen
koalitionsvertrag geben sollte dass
genau diese großen baustellen die sie
gerade angesprochen haben dort erwähnung
finden man wird sicherlich nicht das
rentenalter auf 68 oder 70 erhöhen mit
grün und rot halte ich das für völlig
ausgeschlossen übrigens das für die fdp
auch nicht tun wollen aber erbauen das
ist ja spannend
koalitionsverträge und spiegel striche
und und jetzt vorabfestlegung sind das
eine das haben in den letzten jahren
immer erlebt der regierungsalltag
handlungs zwänge
überraschungsmomente entwicklungen die
man nicht antizipieren kann sie sind ja
eher die regel und deswegen kommt es
jetzt darauf an der internationalität da
sind beweise symbolik jetzt geht's um
vertrauensbildung und darf man eindruck
dass der wille da ist das zeigt dass
alfie der vier das zeigen jetzt diese
verabredung es ist der wille da sich
aufeinander zuzubewegen miteinander
etwas zu tun und wieder jemand kommen ja
stimmen kommen sie sind dabei das ist
nachhaltigkeit ist klimaschutz es ist
die jugend es ist die bildung da wird
man natürlich einiges tun und man wird
auch das thema steuern finanzen in den
blick nehmen da wird man allein klassen
kompromisse schmieden
darum hat wenn man ein kleiner mann
sprechen gleich nochmals zum abschluss
und gucken meine damen und herren gern
noch mal auf einen kleinen überblick
hier und 10 uhr 10 für sie über das was
das gestern abend im sinne der
sondierungsgruppe
denn alles der aktuelle status ist
sie formieren sich fürs gruppenbild
bringen sich in stellung um den wähler
auftrag auszuführen und der ist für die
spd-bundestagsabgeordneten glasklar
formuliert die nächsten vier jahre
werden wir regieren wir haben den
auftrag von vielen wählerinnen und
wählern die uns ein zusätzliches votum
ja auch noch einmal gegeben haben dass
der rote balken so groß nach oben
gegangen ist und die stärkste fraktion
im deutschen bundestag zu sein
korrigieren und das können wir rolf
mützenich ist alter und neuer
fraktionschef mit 97 prozent im amt
bestätigt bei der einweisung der 104
neulinge gibt er die marschroute für die
künftige arbeit vor jeder der einzelnen
abgeordneten weiß dass wir nur in einer
gemeinschaft stark sind jeder soll seine
fachlichkeit seiner überzeugung
eindringen aber nach draußen sind wir
die spd-bundestagsfraktion aller
geschlossenheit zum trotz am ende des
tages könnte die spd macht politisch
gesehen mit leeren händen dastehen denn
für das regieren braucht es partner die
findet man beim sondieren also beim wer
kann mit wem am besten spiel gestern
haben sich schon fdp und grüne zum reden
getroffen ausloten was geht was nicht
111 ii zu später stunde mit
kurzkommentar einziges zeugen auf der
suche nach einer neuen regierung loten
wir gemeinsamkeiten und brücken über
trennendes aus und finden sogar welche
spannende zeiten insofern freue ich mich
darüber dass das gestern ein gutes
gespräch war und sage aber auch jetzt
fehlt noch der dritte partner und das
ist die sozialdemokratie es ist längst
schon kein geheimnis die spd will die
ampel will mit fdp und grünen regieren
liest man zwischen den zeilen dann ist
das auch der grünen chefin liebste
koalition wir haben auch am wahlabend
deutlich gemacht nachdem klar war dass
die spd diese wahl gewonnen hat dass wir
zuerst gespräche mit spd und fdp
führen werden und vor allen dingen dass
wir den auftrag für eine progressive
regierung haben um dieses land zu
erneuern
ebenfalls kein geheimnis die fdp steht
er auf jamaika statt der spd
favorisieren die liberalen das bündnis
mit den zweitplatzierten von cdu und csu
natürlich muss auch über
inhaltliche fragen gesprochen werden
vertieft kann man das oder richtig tief
kann man das allerdings nur in
koalitionsverhandlungen machen und in
welcher konstellation es dazu kommt kann
ich heute nicht zu sagen das ist zu früh
bis sonntag will die fdp auch mit union
und spd geredet haben und so ist bei
aller euphorie über den wahlsieg ein ist
auch ganz klar dass der weg von olaf
scholz geradewegs ins kanzleramt führt
diese messe ist wahrlich noch nicht
geleast
so 10 13 hier bei phoenix meine damen
und herren ist ein langer intensiver
vormittag der uns noch bis nach zwölf
hier live bei uns beschäftigen wird
abschlussfrage mal in dieser erst nach
dieser ersten stunde in der wir sehr
intensiv über all das gesprochen haben
was die letzten tage und die nächsten
tage natürlich im politischen berlin
passiert wie gucken wir jetzt auf das
kommende wochenende ich weiß wir alle
starts ab vormittag aber am wochenende
also morgen noch mal das treffen linke
und grüne dann am wochenende die ersten
treffen mit der spd aber noch keine
dreier konstellation
ja also morgen fdp und grüne und dann am
sonntag wenn ich das richtig eben auch
verfolgt habe ja mit der spd ich glaube
das wird schon eine vorentscheidung mit
sich bringen denn dieses hin und her und
diese unklarheit die union ja oder nein
und wann und wann nicht das sind ja doch
schon indikatoren die skeptisch die
skeptisch stimmen auch für den auch dem
beobachter das heißt also hier ist gar
nicht klar wer erster handlungsfähig
wären entscheidungsfähig will man will
man nicht ich glaube das wort wochenende
hier haben wir dann schon eine gewisse
weggabelung zumindest im hinblick auf
sondierungen die immer mehr auf sich
verfestigen eine weggabelung
die man schlecht wieder zurückkommen
wird also entweder welche sehr die union
klarheit schaffen und offensiv in solche
erst gespräche gehen dürfen nicht
vergessen die fdp hat die hand gereicht
und gesagt wir wollen erst mit der union
sprechen und offenbar kommt nicht dazu
genau das ist ein signal und von daher
gesehen ist das schon eine wichtige
etappe jetzt am wochenende die ein stück
weit mehr klärung bringt vielen dank
professor volker grünberg hierfür die
einschätzungen bis zum jetzigen moment
meine damen und herren wir bleiben
weiter hier im boot gucken auf die
phoenix runde gestern abend die sich
genau mit diesem thema beschäftigt hat
nämlich dem thema kanzler macher und
worauf können sich fdp und grüne den
einigen und dann sind wir direkt danach
wieder hier und schauen weiter auf die
aktualität dieses tages
[Musik]
teambuilding nennt sich wenn etwas
zusammen kommen soll was bisher nicht
zueinander finden konnte oder wollte das
schicksal verschafft jetzt bündnis grüne
und fdp politische tuchfühlung echte
zuneigung wird zwar anders buchstabiert
aber die parlamentarische demokratie ist
da unerbittlich die kanzler machen
worauf einigen sich fdp und grüne jetzt
in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
[Musik]
dieses ziel wurde gestern nacht nach dem
ersten treffen noch losgeschickt die
parteispitzen von fdp und grünen und sie
machen gute miene zum
koalitionspolitische spiel und der dance
elfi wird dazu auf instagram gepostet
auf der suche nach einer neuen regierung
noten hier gemeinsamkeiten und brücken
über trennendes aus und finden sogar
welche spannende zeiten
ja da wollen wir sie mal beim wort
nehmen und damit herzlich willkommen bei
uns meine gäste hier im studio ist
ricarda lang stellvertretende
bundesvorsitzende von bündnis 90/die
grünen und am sonntag frisch in den
bundestag gewählt
wurden von alexander graf lambsdorff der
bundestag schon etwas länger angehört
der stellvertretende vorsitzende der fdp
bundestagsfraktion alexander graf
lambsdorff
zugeschaltet sind ulrike winkelmann
chefredakteurin der taz und johannes
pennekamp ist bei uns der chef der
redakteur bei der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung so lang haben sie
eigentlich vertrauen in die fdp
vertrauen ach ich das ist gar nicht das
ja die frage ist sondern es geht erstmal
darum dass wir einen regierungsauftrag
haben der sich ganz klar aus dem
wahlergebnis ableiten lässt jetzt geht
es darum vertrauen zu schaffen weil ich
darf alles klar 2017 politik des durch
stechens und gegeneinander ausspielen
das darf sich nicht wiederholen man
braucht jetzt eine regierung die wir
einen kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner hat
schon auch eine gemeinsame erzählung das
heißt jetzt ist halt vertrauensbildung
angesagt ramsdorf halten sie ein
scheitern der gespräche zwischen fdp und
bündnisgrünen für möglich
möglich ist alles habe ich sie das
eigentlich nicht ich sehe den
ernsthaften willen beiden partnern genau
wie es die vorsitzenden gesagt haben
diese brücken zu finden da wo es eben
ein bisschen schwieriger ist beide sind
wir jetzt schon ziemlich lange in der
opposition beide sind wir durch das
votum der wählerinnen und wähler am
sonntag ein bisschen stärker noch
geworden wir sind sozusagen in der
situation die sie zum titel ihrer
sendung gemacht haben dass er so ein
bisschen wir in der rolle dieser kanzler
macher parteien geht sind und da wir
aber die beiden sind die in der
vergangenheit auch in der opposition in
den wahlkämpfen sich so ein bisschen
bekannt haben oft ist es richtig dass
wir das jetzt erst mal versuchen
zusammenzubinden also ich bin ja ganz
positiv und optimistisch winkelmann fdp
und bündnisgrüne müssen ja für eine
künftige koalition ganze kröten biotope
schlucken wird das gelingen
ich fürchte es sieht grauenhaft aus dem
läuten biotope schlucken ehrlich zu sein
aber ist alle kröten aus dem biotop
gravierende unterschiede weiterhin gibt
also bei allem charme der die letzten
tage schon versprüht wurde zwischen
grünen fdp und bei allen ermutigungen
die es auch herr lambsdorff gerade auch
noch erwähnt hat denke ich das ist ein
ganz fundamentalen unterschied weiterhin
gibt das ist der dass die fdp sich im
großen und ganzen den besserverdienern
der gesellschaft verpflichtet fühlt und
die grünen aber ganz klar gesagt haben
wir wollen klima schützen wir wollen ihn
sozial und da sehe ich ehrlich gesagt
den großen großen graben pennetta wird
eigentlich mit der union nur noch zum
schein geredet
der eindruck kann man so ein bisschen
haben gerade wenn man auch sieht das die
fdp jetzt sogar die gespräche mit der
union vorziehen wird und ich glaube
schon am samstag mit der union sprechen
wird das kann natürlich ein mittel sein
um druck aufzubauen auf die gespräche
die dann folgen mit der spd also das
wird wirklich spannend sein zu sehen wie
ernst das gemeint wird und die man dann
zu dritt auch reden wird bald über die
terminierung wollte ich eigentlich
später sprechen aber im heute journal
hat volker sind gerade gesagt das glaube
ich dass der am samstag mit der union
möglicherweise nicht klappt mit dem
hipster gründe dafür wissen sie denn er
ist so ich bin gerade ganz knapp vor der
sendung erst angekommen weil wir alle
rum telefonieren im moment ich kann es
ihnen nicht sagen ob es klappt oder
nicht das hat aber wahrscheinlich keine
politischen gründe sondern es sind auch
logistische gründe müssen alle da sein
es gibt termine die es gibt also er
tatsache ist und nicht ob das das
entscheidende es gibt den willen bei
allen beteiligten ernsthaft miteinander
zu sprechen und die frage die sie gerade
gestellt haben wird zum schein mit
einigen gesprochen also ebenfalls von
uns aus nicht das kann ich versichern
also dann setze ich jetzt trotzdem noch
mal nach wir reden ja hier über vor
sondern die zu einer koalition an den
bündnisgrünen fdp beteiligt sein sollen
uns beteiligt werden möchten können wir
uns in diesem zusammenhang von der
jamaika option verabschieden
also wir haben gesagt wir reden mit
allen parteien aber natürlich ist klar
dass die spd vorne lag als wir haben ein
wahlsieger das hat ja keine
gleichwertigen verhandlungs alternativ
man auf der einen seite ist der
gestärkte parteien und wahlsieger haben
auf der anderen seite eine partei mit
einer riesigen wahlschlappe die gerade
auch noch sehr in einem sortierung
prozess ist wer überhaupt
verhandlungsfähig ist der ball liegt aus
meiner sicht jetzt erstmal bei einer
ampel sondierung wir haben auftrag für
eine progressive regierung gekommen ist
ampel und jamaika für die fdp noch
gleich viel wert gleichberechtigt auf
gleicher ebene gleiche ernsthaftigkeit
ja wir sind jetzt drei tage nach
schließung der wahllokale also ich würde
deswegen jetzt eine option vom nicht vom
tisch nehmen wollen ich glaube das wäre
ganz falsch wir müssen schauen dass die
spd in der tat die wahl gewonnen hat die
union hat schwere verluste gehabt dass
beides richtig aber im ergebnis haben
die wählerinnen und wähler am sonntag
die parteien in einem kleinen korridor
von zwei prozent sozusagen in den
bundestag gewählt die grünen haben
zugelegt wir haben zugelegt also ich
denke es wäre falsch jetzt irgendwelche
optionen vom tisch zu nehmen und wie
sich parteien sortieren ist nicht meine
sache das zu kommentieren was bei der
union da passiert ich interpretiere die
entscheidung was die fraktionsführung
dort an geht erstmals eine befriedung
der lage insofern glaube ich dass das
wirklich wichtigste ist dass die grünen
und die freien demokraten
dass dass das trennende überbrücken und
dann mit den beiden reden und schauen wo
gibt es das beste gesamtpaket
das ist noch nicht das ist in meinen
augen ich will das hier deutlich sagen
das ist in meinen augen noch überhaupt
nicht klar ob das bei der ampel oder bei
er michael sein wird so winkelmann
jamaika ist das
wenig am hut schon auf die fragen
geantwortet ist das eigentlich nur noch
steht das noch im raum als option aber
nicht mehr als ganz gemeinde option
hier scheint es keine verhandlungsmasse
und keine reelle option mehr zu sein
also die union hat es wirklich
erfolgreich nach sowie die gelegenheit
auch seit der wahl verpennt und
verbaselt sich noch in ernsthaft
wirklich als als verhandeln spiel zu
bringen und das dürfte und fdp auch klar
sein dass sie beide optionen auf
brauchen um noch scheinbar
ausweichmöglichkeiten zu haben aber es
ist glaube ich ehrlichkeit längst nicht
mehr so herr penny kamen wir reden ja in
der sendung über trennendes und
gemeinsames
bündnis grüne und fdp die sie jetzt zu
sagen wie wir auch dem untertitel des
helfers entnommen haben überbrücken
wollen aber eine gemeinsam gibt es eine
gemeinsamkeit für beide parteien dass
sie jetzt eigentlich fast gezwungen sind
in regierungsverantwortung zu gehen
sonst steht es um ihre zukunft
möglicherweise nicht so gut da wie das
eben schon gesagt wurde beide parteien
waren jetzt lange in der opposition und
sie haben natürlich ein massives
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem
und auch ein problem relevant zu bleiben
bei ihren wählern
wenn sie jetzt nicht die chance
ergreifen in die regierung zu gehen also
es ist anders als vor vier jahren als es
letztlich darum ging wer regiert jetzt
eigentlich weiter mitunter merke dass es
jetzt vorbei jetzt geht es ja wirklich
darum das land zu verändern zu erneuern
das sind das sind erstmal nur große
hatte da muss erst mal jetzt was folgen
aber aber diese chance können sich
eigentlich beide parteien nicht entgehen
lassen wenn sie also glaubwürdig bleiben
wollen schon lange will man das jetzt
mal konstatiert also die fdp hat ja
möglicherweise zwei optionen sie nimmt
jamaika noch ernst die spd hätte ja auch
zwei neben der ampel noch die groko in
der hinterhand sie haben ja durch das
was jetzt auch gerade gesagt haben ja
eigentlich gar keine option erhöhtes den
verhandlungsdruck geradeaus ihre partei
ich glaube wir haben wie die anderen
parteien auch zwei optionen wir sehen
halt dass da eine jetzt der spielball
liegt ich würde vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz weil es gerade so ein bisschen
beschrieben wurde als ob es fast mit
strafe wäre jetzt einen
regierungsauftrag zu bekommen ich glaube
erst mal ist es ein positives zeichen
dass wir von der bevölkerung übrigens
gerade die beiden parteien die jetzt
hier sitzen insbesondere von jungen
wählerinnen den auftrag bekommen haben
eine regierung zu bilden erneuerung zu
bilden aus meiner sicht auch den auftrag
der vielleicht ein bisschen größer ist
sogar als die einzelnen ergebnisse jetzt
klimaschutz wirklich umzusetzen das erst
mal ein riesen chance gut in der auf
diesen aspekt gerade der jungen wähler
und was ihre beiden parteien damit zu
tun haben durch die wahlergebnisse
sonntag kommen wir gleich noch lass uns
doch noch einmal das bild ansehen wenn
wir jetzt auf gemeinsamkeiten das bild
dieses 11 wird dass wir am anfang noch
gezeigt haben das ist also das quartett
der brückenbauer
jetzt soll am freitag weiterverhandelt
werden alexander graf lambsdorff
genügt das eigentlich jetzt am freitag
diese zweite verhandlungsrunde um schon
so viele gemeinsamkeiten zu entdecken
und zu formulieren dass man dann in
einer größeren der möglicherweise zuerst
mit der spd ist und richtige
sondierungen führt also erstmal muss ich
sagen das bild echt cool ich finde dass
mal eine g auf den finals jaja seine
bildsprache die hier mal in der
bundesrepublikanischen politik genutzt
wird könnte gar noch mal einer hinsicht
sogar gut ich lasse sie gelesen haben
über das heute auf twitter los war
deutschlandradio kultur hat er sogar
darum gebeten hätten die silberne und
verkehr im vergleich dazu nahm aber ja
ich finde das zeigt einfach und das sind
dann bin ich bald mit völlig mit
fräulein einverstanden das ist eine
moderne aufbruchs
anmutung in dieses bild dort also bild
sprachlich jetzt hier transportiert und
dass auch der politische anspruch der
beiden parteien die dastehen und der
beiden parteien die heute abend hier
sitzen wir wollen einen aufbruch
schaffen und wir haben bei den erst
wählerinnen und erstwählern unglaubliche
erfolge erzielt also in der eben erst
wenn wir vorne in der jungen gruppe
legen die grünen knapp vorne also das
ist genau das was das bild
transportieren soll und was ist auch
widerspiegelt und ich glaube und nochmal
auf das zurückzukommen so pennekamp
gesagt hat ja natürlich wir sind in
gewisser weise zum erfolg verdammt aber
das ist keine strafe das ist gut und
deswegen sage ich auch es ist wichtig
dass wir ernsthaft über alle optionen
reden und dass diese beiden teams das
jetzt machen am freitag in der zweiten
runde so das ist ein teil eines längeren
prozesses schauen sie wenn wir als freie
demokraten unserem parteitag anfang
dezember gelegt wo wir hoffen ein
ergebnis beraten zu können so das heißt
wir sind jetzt ende september das ist
die zeit bis anfang dezember in der das
ganze organisiert werden soll ich finde
das ist ein überschaubarer
verantwortungsvoller zeitrahmen da
wollen wir jetzt hin verhandeln und es
wird sicherlich das letzte treffen in
dem rahmen bleibt ulrike winkelmann das
soll also ein zeichen des aufbruchs und
des reformwillens seien optisch
festgehalten könnte es auch als drohung
gegen olaf scholz oder arme laschet oder
wen auch immer in der union aufgefasst
werden
es ist auf jeden fall kokett es zeigt so
vieles was
grad schien auch mit aufgezeichnet wurde
wir sind die junge ringe sind die besser
aussehen denn wir sind die cooleren wir
sind die die sich schon auch ganz geheim
und zu ihrer überraschung getroffen
haben an geheimnisvollen ort also
steckte alles drin natürlich steckt
darin eben auch die drohung dass man
eventuell die die spd dann in einer
ampel dann ebenfalls überraschen könnte
mit eben einigungen an ecken und enden
mit denen die sg beweise nicht gerechnet
aber es gibt es am wochenende dann auch
noch anderen sprechen die grünen werden
sich mit der spd treffen denn sicherlich
auch eine große vertrautheit sich fort
beschweren wollen bleiben wir noch bei
den gemeinsamkeiten herr pennekamp
vielleicht ist dann auch schneller
darüber zu reden oder schneller
abzuhaken also wenn man jetzt mal
überlegt wo gibt es gemeinsamkeiten auch
die hier bisher schon das ist der ganze
bereich der sogenannten bürgerrechte
datenschutz migration
digitalisierung bildung fällt ihnen da
noch etwas anderes ein wo es
möglicherweise ganz schnell gehen könnte
oder wo man oder
themen an die man gar nicht so schnell
denkt inzwischen bündnis grünen und fdp
unumstritten sind na ja ich würde würde
das thema migration dann noch dazu
zählen ich glaube beide sind
interessiert daran ein
einwanderungsgesetz zu machen das dann
auch wirklich fachkräfte nach
deutschland holen damit man sich
sicherlich schnell einig und es gibt
sicherlich auch ein paar symbole
symbolische dinge sagen wir mal zb
cannabis legalisierung das ist
sicherlich etwas das dann auch bei den
jüngeren wählern gut ankommt wo man sich
schnell darauf einigt und wo man sagen
kann das haben wir aber das sind dann
natürlich nicht die kernthemen die
kernthemen sind sind klima und steuer
und da stimme ich frau winkelmann zu da
da liegt man doch noch meine leute nach
den ergiebigen ja also ich glaube einer
noch mal ein bisschen was das eigentlich
ausdruck was wir sehen das sehen wir
nicht erst jetzt mit diesem wahltag
sondern eigentlich seit mehreren jahren
ist ein bisschen das ende der ära der
volksparteien und das ist natürlich auch
das ende der ära wo eine partei gewinnt
es gibt ein wahlsieger und dann gibt es
ein bisschen wie zugeordnet parteien für
gerne partei schwitzt schlips die
anderen springen und kommen dazu und ich
glaube das ist das spannende an dieser
konstellation wir haben die größte
schnittmenge mit der spd gerade bei den
themen wo wir es sehr große unterschiede
da trinke man vollkommen recht da werden
wir darauf eingehen in der sozialpolitik
in der steuerpolitik gibt es riesige
unterschiede und da habe ich viele
schnittmengen mit der spd und trotzdem
ist glaube ich diese wechsel eines modus
wie auch seine regierung zusammen kommt
das ist eigentlich das spannende was da
gerade passieren kann und vielleicht
auch was ein bisschen zu einem neuen
politikstil und nach im neuen form des
regierens führen kann also ich glaube
wir haben ein feld noch ausgelassen ich
weiß dass es nicht im zentrum der
aufmerksamkeit steht aber dass ganze
familien recht beispielsweise
selbstbestimmte
sozialen selbstbestimmte entscheidungen
in allen lebenslagen auch am ende des
lebens abschaffung des paragraphen 219 a
lg bietet pure echte holt der werbung ja
dass verträge genau der information das
ist ja fast nur informationen wie es
geht wir haben ganz viele
gesellschaftspolitische nähen zu den
grünen auch weil unsere haben unsere
wähler schafften ähneln sich in
mancherlei hinsicht ja auch und ich
glaube dass es deswegen gelingen wird
ein harter kampf sagt das sind nicht die
kernthemen aber es sind themen die
unheimlich viele menschen in diesem land
betreffen und wenn es dann gelingt
modernisierungsschub reinzukriegen wäre
mir das sehr recht wir haben natürlich
das stimmt in der finanzpolitik
unterschiedliches verständnis wird wie
vor soll der staat machen was soll der
privatsektor machen dann müssen wir
zusammen kommen wird nicht einfach aber
ich halte es auch nicht für
ausgeschlossen
jetzt kommen wir mal zu den knackpunkten
also zu den themen den kernthemen die
umstritten sind das ist die
steuerpolitik hier ist mehrfach das
schon gesagt worden sie wollen die
steuern senken für alle sie wollen die
steuern für sehr gut verdienende
gutverdienende erhöhen es gibt noch
unterschiedliche auffassungen von
schulden bleiben sie wollen sie wieder
einführen sie wollen sie insofern sich
anlocken
also durch anfallende steht im gesetz ja
ausgesetzt durch die crawler pandemie
sie wollen sich insofern lockern als
investitionen in klimaschutz davon nicht
betroffen sein sollen mit einem
sonderfonds vielleicht wenn man sich das
ich will jetzt nicht alles aufzählen ist
es ja auch die nachrichtensendung heute
wieder mehrfach die tabelle und die
verschiedenen kategorien sind ja
aufgezählt worden wenn man sich das
alles die unterschiede zwischen ihren
beiden parteien anzieht dann wäre ein
kompromiss wie immer der einen
koalitionsvertrag aussehe gleich noch
eine der quadratur des kreises
na ja das muss ja erstmal sagen ich habe
vorher schon mal gesagt er mit einer
verantwortung da rein also wenn die
wählerinnen haben ihr votum abgegeben
ich hätte mir auch andere
konstellationen vorstellen könnt jetzt
nicht möglich sind aber erst mal gibt's
ja sozusagen den wählerinnen wären hätte
ich mir auch vorstellen dann müssen ja
irgendwas über daten werfen
einfach sagen als parteien naja das ist
nicht machbar dass wir zusammen finden
und am ende steht da wie eine große
koalition und ich glaube daran hat
wirklich gar niemand in diesem land
irgendein interesse das muss natürlich
versuchen zusammenzufinden und ich
glaube es ist wichtig dass man
leitlinien definiert wir haben die für
uns zum beispiel über die finanzpolitik
anschauen ist klar es müssen mehr
öffentliche investitionen möglich werden
die brauchen wir für den klimaschutz die
brauchen aber auch im bereich der
bildung wenn wir jetzt nicht investieren
und dadurch auch mehr privates geld auch
heben dann bedeutet es einmal dass wir
chancen außen vor lassen die mir bei der
jetzigen zinssätzen gerade haben und
zweitens dass wir uns den zukünftigen
generationen schuldig machen also kann
die ziellinie und dann müssen wir gucken
wie findet man im instrument zusammen
keinen raum für steuererleichterungen
die sich alexander graf lambsdorff
wünscht
uns ist es so erst mal die
schuldenbremse das ganz klar zu sagen
gesteht im grundgesetz und ich glaube
gerade die korona lage hat ja gezeigt in
ausnahmesituationen kann man von ihr
abweichen sie hat übrigens eine
konjunktur komponente dh in der
schwachen konjunktur kann man auch mehr
kredite aufnehmen aber was mir wichtig
ist und ich glaube das ist das
grundprinzip dass mir wirklich wichtig
ist nachhaltigkeit ist ein öko logischer
begriff ist aber auch ein ökonomischer
begriff wenn wir zu viele schulden
aufnehmen wenn wir zurückgehen in das
alte system der exzessiven
staatsverschuldung dann binden wir
kommende generationen durch den
schuldendienst in den bundeshaushalt und
entwerten in der zukunft die
demokratische wahl weil das
haushaltsrecht des parlaments so
eingeschränkt ist dass man gar nicht
mehr den spielraum hat um politische
wirklich prioritäten zu setzen und
deswegen noch mal wir haben viele erst
wählerinnen und erst werde ich vermute
mal bei ihnen die ökologischen und
ökonomischen weil ganz grob gesagt aber
diese nachhaltigkeit idee
gestaltungsspielräume auch in der
zukunft zu erhalten die leitet uns in
unserer haushaltspolitik und deswegen
das ist nicht eine ein rigides
festhalten an einem dogma aus
irgendwelcher verstocktheit sondern ist
es wirklich ein profundes demokratie
politisches denken was dahinter steckt
aber damals mir wenn ich ganz so sagen
darf damit ja darüber sprechen was wir
für einen schulden begriff haben also
verstehen wir schulden nur als die
zahlen die wir nach auf dem konto haben
oder verstehen wir schulden auch als die
frage von in welchen schulen können
zukünftige generationen lernen gibt es
noch ein gesundheitssystem in dem er
mitarbeiten will und natürlich
insbesondere haben wir einen planeten
auf dem es sich noch gut leben lässt
auch das ist eine form von schulden und
das stärkste fahrrad beharren auf der
schuldenbremse führt dazu dass wir in
diesem bereich stärkere schulden fast
schulden für die zukünftigen generation
schaffen auch das ist eine frage von
generationengerechtigkeit und muss
aussagen investitionen schaffen vermögen
machen weil sie haben jetzt geschildert
wofür sie stehen jetzt haben unsere
journalistischen kolleginnen und
kollegen und die winkelmann und johannes
pennekamp aufmerksam zugehört frau
winkelmann was sie da jetzt gehört haben
wie steinig ist in der steuer und
finanzpolitik der weg zur einigung erst
mal zwischen den grünen und der fdp
bevor es dann mit dem großen parkplatz
eingemachte geht
also die fdp hat sich darauf festgelegt
die schuldenbremse erhalten zu wollen
und auch offiziell nicht unterschätzen
zu wollen und das ging ja auch ohnehin
mit der zweidrittelmehrheit die wir ja
nicht bekommen werden da voraussicht
nach worauf aber sowohl grüne als auch
die sich intern auf
einigen konnten war dass man ja die
schuldenbremse vielleicht einfach mal
beiseite
stehen lässt und stattdessen sogenannte
sondervermögen schafft also fonds heißt
es dass man auch die im wesentlichen
auch steuerfinanziert sind alsfeld
besteht aber aus denen man dann
investitionen tätigen und nach allem was
ich lese und höre es darauf hinauslaufen
dass tatsächlich kommen und wie sich
darauf einigen könnten nach dem motto
schuld brennt schon gut lassen wir mal
so stehen was man nicht weiter an aber
aus großen sonnen
wird aber im moment ein bild und ton
problemen zu unrecht winkeln
magnetisierung und
probieren sie es nochmal vor winkelmann
jetzt glaube ich da immer besser
geworden es tut mir leid ich weiß gar
nicht wo ich unterbrochen wurde
sie haben dass du nicht zu den schulden
bleiben sie gesagt ich begeben hat das
wort weiter an johannes pennekamp jetzt
wird schuldenbremse steuerpolitik
senkung erhöhung wie geht man mit dem
soli um gibt es einen höheren
spitzensteuersatz wird ja verhandelt
jetzt zwischen oder sondiert zwischen
bündnisgrünen fdp aber möglicherweise
machen ja die beiden dann die rechnung
ohne den wirt denn da gibt es ja zum
beispiel die spd die gerade in diesem
bereich steuer und finanzpolitik ganz
und gar eigenen vorstellungen hat und
immerhin ja der größte der
koalitionspartner der künftigen ist geht
das ganze dann von vorne los und was ist
dann eine einigung zwischen fdp und
grünen wert
ja also ich denke zwischen grünen und
spd ist die schnittmenge da schon
relativ groß das heißt für mich dass
eine einigung zwischen fdp und grünen
dann schon schon die richtung zumindest
anzeigt ich glaube die schuldenbremse
müssen wir gar nicht groß reden die
steht im grundgesetz die wird nicht
gegen den willen der union
verschwinden das heißt wie frau
winkelmann das gesagt hat die
wahrscheinliche lösung ist dass man eben
mit mit staatlichen sonderfonds agiert
die dann zweckgebunden für für
investitionen für klima ausgaben zum
beispiel genutzt werden also dass das
scheint mir eine realistische option
und ansonsten in steuerfragen wird es
sicherlich auch einen kompromiss gehen
der in die richtung geht das der der
soli wegfällt den ja sowieso das
bundesverfassungsgericht abräumen wird
und man dann sich aber vielleicht darauf
einige den spitzensteuersatz etwas zu
erhöhen vielleicht etwas später
einsetzen zu lassen als heute da käme
dann jeder so ein bisschen auf seine
kosten das heißt ja ein kompromiss ist
möglich aber es wird so ein bisschen so
ein so ein laues lüftchen am ende
glauben gut dann nehme ich das nochmal
auf und wiederhole noch mal meine frage
und wir probieren es nochmal mit ulrike
winkelmann was sich wenn sich da als
eine einigung abzeichnet zwischen
bündnisgrünen fdp
könnte dass sie wie gesagt ja insofern
vergeblich gewesen seien als die spd
sagt nehmen mit uns machen das so nicht
dann wird alles wieder aufgetrennt was
bedeutet dass auch für die
koalitionsverhandlung dass man jetzt
sozusagen auf ganz unterschiedlicher
ebene verhandelt erst mal die beiden
kleineren und dann eben im 3er
konsortium wird dass die verhandlungen
erschweren
natürlich natürlich ist es schwerer sich
mit drei leuten zu einigen als oder mit
drei parteien als mit 2 1 aber in die
sache mit dem sonderform zum beispiel
scheint mir doch weit verbreitet zu sein
und auch weitgehend zustimmung auch in
spd reihen zu finden das ist einfach
jetzt schon letzten anderthalb
vielleicht so schon zwei jahre in allen
parteien auch diskutiert worden ein
anderer punkt ist dann eben welche die
messstation investitionen nicht aus
unserem iphone finanziere und ob ich
gleichwohl dann noch steuersenkungen
versprechen kann hier das ja die fdp tue
und spätestens da werden sich grüne und
spd zusammenfinden und zwar gegen die sg
dann wird es vielleicht zu kleinen
verschiebungen kommen kann wird eine
kann gerade andeutete man könnte zum
beispiel die abschaffung des soli halten
eine reform der einkommenssteuer
verbergen oder investor einbauen aber
dann ist natürlich dann auch so
schwierig das heißt aber die fdp
anhänger und wähler die die ihre partei
gewählt haben die werden ja sagen kommt
mir bloß nicht ohne steuersenkung nach
hause wie gehen sie dann mit dieser
situation um wenn sie da keinen
widerhall ich bin also ein bisschen
erstaunt für die schon dass wir alles
schon wissen und sozusagen was schon
klar sein soll also zu den sonderfonds
da sind wir eher skeptisch was sowas
angeht einfach aus dem grund dass das
natürlich neben haushalte sind es gibt
instrumente mit förderbanken über die
man reden kann aber das ist ein anderes
ist ein anderer hebel demeter machen
sowohl diese vorstellung der spd
also es gibt durchaus möglichkeiten was
zu tun aber solche neben fonds sind
immer etwas hinter der vergangenheit
haben wir das kritisch gesehen dass er
eine punkte zweiter punkt ich sage ich
mir jetzt was das wird sie überraschen
die fdp möchte das steueraufkommen
insgesamt erhöhen in der frist also auf
der zeitschiene und wir glauben dass wir
das dadurch schaffen dass wir eben
entlasten investitionsanreize schaffen
denn wenn frau lang von investitionen
spricht im öffentlichen sektor dann ist
das völlig okay und ich stimme ihnen zu
wir müssen natürlich auch öffentliche
investitionen machen ist gar keine frage
na ob das schulgebäude sind
breitbandausbau klima und so weiter aber
jeder euro den wir es öffentlich
investieren dem stehen acht bis neun
euro gegenüber die an privater
liquidität da sind und investiert werden
sollen und wir haben schon vor corinna
eine situation gehabt dass der wert der
abschreibungen in deutschland höher war
als die werte neuinvestitionen wir haben
also eine schleichende
deindustrialisierung gehabt und das
wollen wir umdrehen weil eines ist
vollkommen klar alle sozialen ziele alle
ökologischen ziele alle technologischen
ziel der öffentlichen hand erreichen wir
nur auf der grundlage einer starken
wirtschaft die uns dieses
steueraufkommen generiert und deswegen
ist eine entlastung in der kurzen frist
der weg hin zu mehr investitionen zb
neue abschreibungsregelungen hin zu
einem höheren steueraufkommen und mehr
handlungsfähigkeit des staates aber ich
hab einen kampf mit sich da gerade
dank ich wollte kurz kurz noch einfügen
wir können dieses thema eigentlich nicht
nicht diskutieren ohne mal kurz darüber
nachzudenken wie es im haushalt
eigentlich aussieht man muss ich
vielleicht noch einmal kurz bewusst
machen im kommenden jahr fehlen im
haushalt 100 milliarden euro es werden
100 milliarden euro strukturell mehr
ausgegeben als wir an einnahmen haben
das geht noch weil die weil die
schuldenbremse ausgesetzt ist schon im
jahr danach muss das wieder reduziert
werden auf ungefähr zehn milliarden dh
es muss massiv gespart werden und sparen
kann man ja natürlich auch in dem man
ausgaben kürzt und gerade da sehe ich
eigentlich auch die fdp in der pflicht
da jetzt ein paar vorschläge zu liefern
und erstaunt mich ein bisschen dass wir
da noch so wenig darüber gesprochen
haben viel über über steuerreform
steuererhöhungen steuersenkungen aber
es geht ja worauf sich einigen können
dass gegensteuert und dann vielleicht
das ganz kurz abschließen können das
wäre vielleicht überraschend hier ich
glaube es ist für niemand überraschen
dass die fdp auf den titel down effekt
setzt also die vorstellung alles
funktioniert ja nicht anders sieht man
lassen da kann man jetzt schon mal sich
anschauen was sogar den us präsident joe
biden sagt also
erklären da hast du das langsam nach
durch steuerentlastungen investitionen
anreizen und dann gehen die steuern
haben und dann für immer muss schon
einmal sagen die vorstellung bei den
zahlen hier gerade genannt worden also
bei der schwierigen haushaltslage die
wir zahlen wir bleiben bei der
schuldenbremse und gleichzeitig
berichtet auf steuererleichterung
insbesondere für die menschen die schon
unglaublich viel haben also entlasten
verein besser verdient das ist ja
finanzpolitisches kam
irgendwie einen die wahl kamen hier
gerade wieder passiert er ist ja einigen
das war ja die frage der einigung also
der punkt ist folgender es geht hier
nicht um einen sozusagen reagan nomics
rachel reid trickle down effekt um
sozusagen über die ganzen horror
gespenster der sozusagen linkeren
ökonomik hier zu mobilisieren und worum
es tatsächlich geht ist dass wir einen
unternehmens steuersystem braune
körperschaftsteuer einkommenssteuer das
uns wettbewerbsfähig macht wir haben wir
sehen es in frankreich die wachsen
schneller aus der krise heraus als wir
wir sehen uns in italien die wachsen
doppelt so schnell aus der krise heraus
wie wir wir haben ihre steuerreform noch
die amerikaner haben es gemacht die
chinesen hab's gemacht also es gibt eine
ganze reihe von ländern die diesen weg
gegangen sind und der punkt ist der wir
müssen als standort auch für
investitionen attraktiv sein das heißt
wir müssen ja auch leute anziehen die
hier investieren wir freuen uns alle
über idol maske und die firma hier in
brandenburg aber so was brauchen wir
öfter also wir brauchen mehr firmen die
hier investieren und jobs schaffen eine
starke wirtschaft ist die wirklich
absolut unabdingbare grundlage dafür
dass wir diese ziele erreichen und noch
mal das ist nicht spickel daun das ist
ein leistungsfähiger staat der auf der
grundlage einer leistungsfähigen
wirtschaft seine ziele erreichen kann
und das ist mir ganz wichtig übrigen
parteien eine ausgabe die ich ihn sofort
sagen kann die wir streichen würden sind
subventionen für elektroautos es gibt
überhaupt keinen grund elektroautos zu
subventionieren diejenigen die sich die
leisten können der sind und die sind
inzwischen den massenmarkt angekommen
können die auch selber bezahlen also
2000 euro über den lebenszyklus eines e
autos sind eine überflüssige trotzdem
einen break machen ich kann mir
vorstellen dass die arbeitsgruppe die
sich bei koalitionsverhandlungen mit
steuerpolitik
beschäftigt vor allem von leuten
wahrscheinlich oder die leute einziehen
werden die relativ wenig schlaf brauchen
werden und lange verhandeln können das
ist in den anderen gruppen aus
und
schon mal angeklungen die bei den
erstwählern haben 23 prozent das hat
viele überrascht
die fdp und 22 die grünen deshalb
weniger überrascht gewählt also 23
prozent fdp gerade diese wähler sagen es
geht uns auch ums klima aber genauso
wichtig sind digitalisierung und
innovation wenn man jetzt diese punkte
mal zusammen zieht was die jungen wähler
23 und 22 prozent das sind fast die
hälfte aller jungwähler die airline fdp
und bündnisgrüne wählen ist das der
bereich der sich ja auch ergänzt der eng
zusammenhängt wo sich fdp und
bündnisgrünen vielleicht sogar einigen
können das heißt dass die jungwähler die
erstwähler die beiden parteien erst
drauf gebracht haben wo eigentlich der
knackpunkt liegt und wo auch eine
einigung möglich ist so eine koalition
ja ich glaube dass hier eine generation
sich darauf einigen können dass sie in
der pandemie schlecht vernachlässigt
wurde also nach den jungen leuten wurde
einfach zuletzt gefragt nicht nur die
schülerinnen und schüler sondern auch
die studierenden sind schlicht abgehängt
worden und nach den hat niemand geschaut
und sind vollkommen zu recht sauer auf
alles was großkoalitionär riecht oder
das was von spd und schädigen und csu
regiert worden ist und hier finden sich
sicherlich die grünen und die fdp
wählerinnen und wähler in den jüngeren
jahrgängen wobei man nicht vergessen
darf dass die bildungsministerin
minister übrigens ihren bundesländern ja
auch von unter einem grünen gestellt
werden aber ich glaube das ist sehr viel
auch damit zu tun hat wie die fdp sich
geregnet hat die letzten jahre dass da
sehr viele junge leute weil sie darauf
anspringen christian endter ist ja quasi
zum influenza eigentlicher weise seiner
partei auch montiert durch die enorme
social media präsenz und so weiter und
sofort hat er da einfach auch ästhetisch
geschmacklich nerv getroffen bei den 18
bis 24 jährigen während die grünen er
doch die jungen leute anziehen die
schlicht das klima im mittelpunkt
stellen und sich sagen wir sind die
generation die von den jetzt bisher
regiert haben den generationen auch
im grunde ebenfalls wichtig wie man
politik hinten angestellt worden sind
wir hier müssen es ausbaden was die
großkoalitionäre von zu verbockt haben
wir sind schon das war ja auch
unterschiedliche sorgen betroffenheit es
passt sozusagen in rationell zu sagen
auch nicht unbedingt in der sache
wirklich ganz kurz zu sagen wenn jemand
schon recht das ästhetisch
geschmackliche spielt sicher eine rolle
aber das wäre alleine nicht ausreichend
ich glaube das muss man das will ich
hier nochmal sagen denn das ist der
internet steht ein lebensgefühl das ist
dieses lebensgefühl toleranz
weltoffenheit aber eben auch
leistungsbereitschaft aufstiegswillen
rationalität optimismus das ist ein
ganzes lebensgefühl und das ist bei
jungen leuten eines das man dass man das
können sie mit händen greifen wenn sie
auf fdp veranstaltungen gehen wenn der
christian lindner auf den marktplätzen
der republik spricht da stehen die leute
schlange um cell festzumachen 100 140
hunderte junger leute die diese die sich
von diesem lebensgefühl angesprochen
fühlen es wird dann umgesetzt das stimmt
in der ästhetik aber es ist nicht nur
die ästhetik dahinter steht mehr gut
dahinter könnte ja auch jetzt zum thema
klima noch mal woanders stecken in bezug
auf die grünen frei des for future zum
beispiel junge menschen die sagen das
ist unsere zukunft und den älteren
vorwerfen ihr ruiniert die gerade durch
euer konsumverhalten aber haben die
grünen vielleicht übersehen dass eben
nicht alle jugendlichen das klima so
absolut setzen sondern ich habe ja
gerade die beiden anderen punkte genannt
digitalisierungen innovation für sie
genauso wichtig ist ich glaube erst mal
gesagt das ergebnis der fdp war
überraschend war für mich auch
überraschend trotzdem halte ich gar
nichts davon was jetzt auch teile so ein
bisschen sozialen medien stattgefunden
hat dass man sich da fast über die
wählerin lustig machten diese generation
das so ein bisschen fertig macht dafür
erst mal muss man das ernst nehmen dass
ich da ganz viele junge wählerinnen so
entschieden haben ich glaube wir müssen
ein bisschen davon wegkommen gerne
generation zu homogenisieren also die
junge generation bild dass das
offensichtlich haben wählerin von fdp
und grünen erst mal sehr
unterschiedliche politische ansichten
und unterschiedliche politische
interessen und das gilt offensichtlich
auch für die junge generation
was man aber tatsächlich sehen kann ich
glaube einmal dieses vergessen werden in
der pandemie was frau winkelmann
angesprochen hatte und das vergessen von
zukunftsthemen also dass dieses gefühl
glaube ich in einer jüngeren generation
von klimaschutz digitalisierung das sind
ja nicht ganz zufälligerweise genau die
themen die die große koalition liegen
lassen hat in den letzten jahren und da
geht jetzt eine riesige
erwartungshaltung eine neue regierung
und da muss mehr aussagen beim
klimaschutz wird sich jede regierung
egal wie sie zusammensetzen wird andere
ende an der realität als ein pariser
klimaabkommen und unseren
klimaschutzzielen messen lassen wir
wollen uns an der da auch an der
realität orientieren zunächst mal herr
pennekamp war es das klima angeht da
gibt es ja durchaus auch unterschiede
zwischen fdp und bündnisgrünen mal kurz
zusammengefasst die fdp sagt soll
wesentlichen der markt mit entscheiden
technologieoffenheit das muss gefördert
werden
den klimawandel also besser gesagt den
klimaschutz zu forcieren die grünen
sagen da muss es klare gesetzliche
vorgaben geben also auch staatlicher
einfluss wie kann das zusammengehen denn
dass sie da auch ganz unterschiedliche
jahr
grundsätzliche prinzipielle politische
herangehensweisen
haben sie jetzt auch bei uns der staat
ganz sicher ganz sicher das sind große
probleme da gibt es jetzt auch keine
pauschale antwort wie das zusammengehen
wird also da müssen sich beide seiten
bewegen und ja die fdp kommt über den
marktmechanismus sagt wir müssen ganz
viel über den emissionshandel und den
co2 preis regeln was ökonomisch total
sinnvoll ist das ist der der günstigste
weg sozusagen zu mehr klimaschutz man
muss dann aber wenn es hart auf hart
kommt auch dazu stehen und nicht nicht
zum beispiel wie herr lindner wenn der
benzinpreis steigt dann direkt sagen wir
brauchen eine benzinpreis bremse also
dass das passt nicht zusammen das muss
man dann konsequent machen und ja die
grünen die grünen haben glaube ich
gelernt dass man mit vielen vielen
aussagen da auch nicht nicht nur auf
wohlwollen stößt also als frau berbalk
im wahlkampf dann wieder sagte jedes
verbot ist ein innovationstreiber hat
das glaube ich im wahlkampf auch nicht
gerade geholfen und und diese denkweise
in der klimapolitik führt auch nicht
weiter das heißt das wird sehr
interessant wie die dann miteinander
klarkommen die frage ist ja wie soll es
jetzt weitergehen mit dem klima man kann
ja sagen man überlässt das
innovationsentwicklung das kann aber
sein dass es dann auf der zeitschiene
durchaus länger dauert da werden dann
die grünen unruhig dieser magnet es muss
schneller gehen denn wir haben ja klare
zeitliche vorgaben was die
klimaneutralität angeht das pariser
klimaabkommen da muss man auch staatlich
da muss man politisch nachhelfen also
was wir gesagt haben ist und dass nicht
viele es noch mal so zu sagen was ihm
gerade so gefragt die fdp sagt der markt
soll alles regeln ein der staat setzt
den rahmen also das ist ja sozusagen
klassische ordoliberale ansatz der staat
setzt einem rahmen in dem dann
marktmechanismen würden aber der rahmen
das ist das klima budget das ist die
zahl an tonnen die wir noch ausstoßen
können und jede einzelne tonne kriegt
ihren preis und das ist erkennbar dass
richtig gesagt ist der günstigste
effektivste weg die bei den geringsten
vermeiden wir den geringsten
vermeidungskosten tatsächlich die
meisten einsparungen zu erreichen
ergänzend klima außenpolitik wir
brauchen auch nach außen eine stärkere
einbindung der anderen aber ein punkt
ist mir auch wichtig und das ist glaube
ich von entscheidend ab sie haben gerade
gesagt
wenn man das so macht dann darf man auf
gar keinen fall an anderen
stellschrauben drehen nein ich kann nur
daran erinnern was in frankreich
passiert ist als emanuel makro aus gutem
willen die pariser klimaschutzziele zu
erreichen
eine verkehrspolitische maßnahmen
gemacht hat mit dem tempolimit auf den
landstraßen und mit der erhöhung der
preise für sprit das hat die geld festen
proteste im ganzen land ausgelöst da ist
die formulierung von ihnen herr keller
oder sie haben es gesagt erkennen kann
dass nicht jede äußere regine maßnahme
sofort auf wohlwollen stößt ist ja noch
milde also ist wir müssen so machen wir
müssen diesen umbau der gesellschaft
richtung klimaneutralität so machen dass
alle mitgehen können deswegen haben die
grünen ein klima geld wir haben eine
klima dividende das sind dinge woher
soll ich aber
laufen dann aber ein durchaus durchaus
parallel in der denke der die richtung
ist klar wir reden über die instrumente
und wir reden über feintuning bei der
dämpfung von bestimmten wirkungen und
das waren eine gewalttätige und
aggressive geld westen bewegung wollen
sie in deutschland auch nicht
provozieren man muss ja der ehrlichkeit
halber sagen dass die gelb westen wegen
mich einfach nur daher kam dass
klimaschutzmaßnahmen gemacht wurden
sondern dass man dergleichen dreist und
über eine lange zeit die soziale
ungleichheiten diesem land massiv
zugenommen hat und das ist natürlich
eine explosive mischung weil man eine
krasse soziale ungleichheit hat und dann
noch das gefühl hat okay jetzt werden
wir ein schnapsglas ich drauflos lage in
den bulli oder müssen wir ganz klar
sagen klimaschutz wenn er gut gemacht
hat dann verschärft dass soziale
ungleichheit nicht aber er kann sie auch
nicht selbst aufheben dafür brauchst du
soziale politik dafür braucht eine gute
arbeitsmarktpolitik deshalb wollen wir
ja und ich glaube dass wir wieder mit
der spd sehr gemeinsam den mindestlohn
endlich auf 12 euro anheben ich glaube
trotzdem dass bild was hier teilweise ja
nicht nur hier immer wieder gezeichnet
wird die grünen wollen nur staat die fdp
will nur markt das ist ja ein verzerrtes
bild sie haben den ordnungsrechtlichen
punkt in ihrem programm und wir sagen
klar die märkte der zukunft werden
klimaneutral sein was eigentlich der
springende punkt ist und das wird glaube
ich auch der schwierige
verhandlungspunkt seien es welche rolle
nimmt der preis ein weil das was hier
als konzept haben ist ja am ende ein
konzept wo der preis eigentlich
sozusagen das entscheidende kriterium
und der entscheidende maßstab wird das
ist mein und sich ziemlich schnell und
sozial selbst wenn man wie es ja sagen
energie geld macht oder wie sie es sagen
eine klima dividende kann das einst so
stark steigenden co2 preis kaum
aufhalten und es wird natürlich dazu
werden dann gerade menschen ländlichen
raum die können zu wenig auto fahren
kaum noch leisten aber es gibt noch
keine alternative es gibt noch keine
satz es gibt dort kein bus keine bahn
dafür brauchen wir investitionen dafür
brauchen wir ordnungsrecht und dafür
brauchen wir ihn konkret offensive
zwischen klima und sozialpolitik jetzt
kommen auf unseren untertitel zurück
worauf können sie sich einigen glauben
sie dass da eine einigung möglich ist
wir müssen jetzt nicht jedes detail
durch diskutieren wollen den
arbeitsgruppen ja nicht vorgreifen also
insofern wir führen ja auch keine
koalitionsverhandlungen im fernsehstudio
das würden wir alles und wirken
wahnsinnig sympathisch aber
das ist ja dass es auch erkennen kann
bei am anfang sagte was auch sie gefragt
haben wir können ihnen heute abend hier
nicht sagen weder verlangt auch ich wo
wir uns da genau treffen werden was wir
ihnen versichern können dass auch den
zuschauern und zuschauern aber
versichern können ist es beide parteien
wirklich ernsthaft an diesen prozess
rangehen das auszuhandeln das ist das
mandat dass uns die menschen in diesem
land gegeben haben und natürlich wird
das schlaflose nächte bedeuten und ewig
lange sitzungen und ganz klar aber wir
werden am ende da bin ich wirklich
zuversichtlich ist schaffen mit einem
konzept rauszukommen das dann auch mehr
sein wird als nur so ein sohn lauer
profis erkennen kann hat also die
befürchtung da eben geäußert ich gehe
noch mal zurück zu dem foto der ist der
wille da diese modernisierung zu
schaffen wir haben die erst wähler
angesprochen klimaschutz digitalisierung
grüne fdp es passt eigentlich wirklich
gut zusammen wir müssen das jetzt
hinkriegen da bin ich wirklich fest von
überzeugt gut das haben sie am anfang
auf die frage gedacht ist diese
gespräche dürfen nicht scheitern und
ricke winkelmann wenn wir mal auch auf
die koalitionspolitische
koalitionspolitische ebene zurückkehren
wer hat denn jetzt das heft des handelns
in der hand das ist ja ein
der vorgang den wir diese woche erleben
zwei kleine partner wollen sich erst mal
einigen der größere oder beide größere
stehen wie bestellt und nicht abgeholt
am spielfeldrand und gucken zu bis man
sich geeinigt hat und bis man dann am
wochenende möglicherweise zu einem
termin gebetet gebeten wird wie sieht
das aus oder wie muss man sich das jetzt
vorstellen werden auch in den
koalitionsverhandlungen fdp und grüne
wir gehen sie mal davon aus mit der spd
auch da die dominierenden faktoren seien
oder wie sich die spd dann noch ins
spiel bringen
die spd hat sich bisher
nicht so blöd angestellt dass man
unterstellen müsste das jetzt irgendwie
untergeht in den spielen und natürlich
haben grüne und spd auch schon längere
zeit nach gemeinsamkeiten sicherlich
besucht und haben sich überlegt wie sie
die seine speziellen umverteilungs
vorstellungen der fdp ein bitten können
und einbinden können und ich bin mir
recht sicher dass die fdp natürlich
erstmal jetzt gut beraten waren sich als
erstes zu treffen dass dann aber dass
das eigentliche spiel lauten wird das
grüne und spd zusammen überlegen können
müssen die weite der fdp entgegenkommen
und die fdp hat eben die drohung immer
noch diese zocken kann damit dass sie im
zweifel alles platzen lässt und quasi
zur union marschiert das ist ja nicht
aus der welt obwohl ich mir gesagt
glaube das ist nicht sehr wahrscheinlich
ist weil weil die union sich auch in so
vieler anderer hinsicht in den letzten
tagen und wochen unmöglich gemacht
was glauben sie wie die
koalitionsverhandlungen verlaufen werden
mit dem unterschied zu den früheren
jahren wo es einen mächtigen player gab
und der konnte sich sogar manchmal die
koalitionspartner aussuchen
ja ganz schwierig also ich denke im
moment entsteht ja manchmal so ein
bisschen das bild als als würden spd
tschuldigung fdp und grüne gemeinsame
sache machen und könnten sich den
kanzler hinterher aussuchen ich glaube
so wird es nicht kommen und die
kleineren parteien müssen auch ein
bisschen aufpassen dass sie ihr blatt
nicht über überreizen und damit auf die
nase fallen also dieses dieses elfi und
so weiter das demonstriert eine
einigkeit dass das kann auch als
provokation anderswo aufgefasst werden
also ich wage keine prognose und
schließe die groko am ende nicht ganz
aus gut das blatt nicht überreizen ist
ein stichwort rolf mützenich der heute
frisch gewählte fraktionsvorsitzende der
spd hat gestern gesagt bei den kleinen
parteien damit hat er ihre beiden
parteien gemeint muss klar sein dass das
schauspiel von vor vier jahren auf den
balkon hier bei der parlamentarischen
gesellschaft bei den jamaika
sondierungen der aufgabe nicht gerecht
wird vor dem man steht jetzt kann man
sagen das was man damals der gesehen hat
aber anja ihre beiden parteien auch
beteiligt dass man hier sagen manchmal
ein bisschen albern aus aber die art wie
rolf mützenich das jetzt formuliert hat
das vom zungenschlag ging so ein
bisschen wie eine gouvernante die ihren
schutzbefohlenen sagt wo es langgeht wie
ist das ein hinweis darauf ist
möglicherweise in den
koalitionsverhandlungen zu wenn sie
nicht gut ist dass köln ich bin aus bonn
er hat ja recht da sind zum teil bilder
entstanden die nicht so glücklich waren
und ich glaube es sind sich alle einig
dass man diesmal nicht sozusagen wieder
irgendwo herkommen kleinen parteien ich
meine sie zusammen so stark
dass ein zeichen auf seinen anspruch
verlieren muss und ich glaube worauf
sich wahrscheinlich tatsächlich alle
einigen können ist es sollte kein
sondierung geben die bis 2017 laufen wo
dauernd durch gestochen wird wo es wenig
vertraulichkeit gibt wo jedes bild über
interpretiert wird ich glaube das wird
wichtig sein ernsthafte sondierungen zu
haben vertrauliche sondierungen zu haben
und welche die nicht das ziel haben
nachher eine komplementär koalition ihr
kriegt ein bisschen was da ihr kriegt
ein bisschen was da sondern der technik
gemeinsam erzählung und da bin ich
tatsächlich bei herr mützenich es
braucht eine regierung diesen
herausforderungen rentiert also der
klimakrise herr zu werden die soziale
ungleichheit zu verringern und endlich
eine politik auf der höhe von einer
modernen einwanderungsgesellschaft zu
machen und wenn er das auch so sieht
dass man sich an dem orientieren sollte
ist es auch super und winkelmann wenn er
es doch nicht so klappt wie man sich
jetzt vorstellt mit der ampel und
jamaika doch wieder ein spiel kennt wäre
ein die option für die bündnisgrünen und
die fdp mit der union vielleicht doch
ernsthaft zu verhandeln aber ohne armin
laschet
das wäre sicherlich eine option die dann
benannt würde aber die union ist im
augenblick nicht im stande zu sagen wie
sie mit armin laschet weiter umgehen
will und wie wieder weiter verhandelt
und gehandelt werden soll daher reicht
meine fantasie aktuell nicht wie das
hinaussehen per panic union mit oder
ohne laschet wenn sie noch mal ein spiel
käme
ja also ich sehe da ein großes
legitimationsproblem wenn man da jetzt
einen anderen spitzenkandidaten als
armin laschet hinstellt also dass das
sehe ich im moment nicht wir hatten ja
kannst rielle wo ein kanzlerkandidat
aufgetreten das danach einen anderen
kanzler zu wählen das kann ich mir kaum
vorstellen kann sie beide frau lang und
ramsdorf würde ich gerne eine letzte
frage stellen da kann man mit einem
einzigen wort antworten
gestatten sie mir oder entschuldigen sie
die frage wer wird der nächste
finanzminister sein robert habeck oder
christian lindner
ja also ich würde sagen christian
lindner
das hat auch gute gründe wir haben einen
wahlkampf gemacht indem es insbesondere
eine starke wirtschaft soliden haushalt
steuerreform geht und wenn wir diese
ziele dann in die tat umsetzen wollen es
ist richtig dass unser spitzenkandidat
das ministerium anstrebt außerdem
herausholen als hinterhältig die fdp in
die ampel locken ich würde sagen all das
was ich gerade eben über die sondierung
gesagt hat bedeutet eben auch dass man
keine personaldebatten im fernsehen wird
wir klären jetzt erstmal die inhalte die
personaldebatten kommen danach das war
eine erwartbare antwort ich bedanke mich
dass ich hier war andré kather lang
alexander graf lambsdorff und ricke
winkelmann und johannes pennekamp liebe
zuschauer morgen in der phoenix runde
auf dem weg ins kanzleramt hat scholz
die spd im griff bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]
so meine damen und herren ich hab gar
noch mal geschaut das war ja ein guter
von alexander keller auf die phoenix
runde heute abend hat die spd hat oder
scholz die spd im griff darüber wollen
wir hier sprechen an tag 4 nach der
bundestagswahl und irgendwie ist alles
im fluss allerhand abstimmungstermin
zwischen den verschiedenen parteien und
fraktionen untereinander auf dem weg zu
einer neuen bundesregierung irgendwann
in einigen wochen wahrscheinlich eher
monaten also herzlich willkommen meine
damen und herren hier zurück zu königs
vor ort so da sind wir bei der spd was
macht die eigentlich die ja
wahlgewinnerin sitzt fast ein bisschen
unbeteiligt am rand und beobachtet hat
man so ein bisschen fast das gefühl es
gibt eine neue chance auf einen aufbruch
hat carsten schneider heute morgen im
ard morgenmagazin gesagt der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der
spd-bundestagsfraktion ein neuer
aufbruch warten wir erst mal ab auf
jeden fall herrscht gute stimmung in der
spd
laola für den neuen helden der
sozialdemokraten so euphorisch ist olaf
scholz in seiner karriere nicht oft
begrüßt worden auch parteichefin saskia
esken ordnet sich brav nach dem 1 der
neue starke mann wird akzeptiert erstmal
das kann natürlich zu schwierigen
situationen kommen wenn es jetzt um
kompromisse geht aber dahin wird es
letztlich nicht scheitern man weiß dass
das jetzt eine chance ist ein
sozialdemokratischen kanzler zu haben
insofern glaube ich schon dass die
disziplin die ja bemerkenswert hoch
gewesen ist in der vergangenheit auch in
der zukunft durchaus hoch bleiben wird
bei der traditionell streitlustigen spd
stellt sich allerdings immer gleich die
frage hält das auch oder ist die
harmonie nur fassade stillhalten auf dem
weg zur macht man kriegt uns auch nicht
auseinanderdividiert denn wir sind für
dasselbe politische programm angetreten
wir sind ja als spd angetreten und nicht
als einzelperson wir haben auch nicht
einfach behauptet geschlossen zu sein
sondern wir haben ja was dafür getan
nämlich unsere programmatischen
baustellen die haben wir abgearbeitet
der neue zusammenhalt harter arbeit der
wieder gewählte fraktionschef ebenfalls
ein parteilinker hat jedenfalls schon
mal die linie vorgegeben
es ist eine große aufgabe insbesondere
weil wir uns einig darüber sind so
schnell wie möglich olaf scholz zum
kanzler der bundesrepublik deutschland
zu wählen so viel harmonie und freudige
gesichter hat man jedenfalls bei der spd
lange nicht gesehen also man müsste uns
ja fast alle ein bisschen wecken aber
ist das noch die gleiche spd wie vor ein
paar monaten und hält eigentlich diese
disziplin die wir da sehen professor
volker grund werk politikwissenschaftler
von der universität bonn sie haben schon
nicht als die frage gestellt habe so von
wegen darüber müssen wir sprechen also
es ist jetzt eine neue spd
auf einmal naja es ist ja nicht eine
neue spd aber es ist tatsächlich eine
spd mit neuen oder zumindest lange nicht
erlebten verhaltensweisen diese
geschlossenheit die man ja über wochen
ja monate erlebt hat in diesem wahlkampf
unterscheidet sich signifikant von den
vorangegangenen kandidaturen und
wahlkämpfen mit denen jeweils sehr
enttäuschenden ergebnissen so war wie er
sich denn geändert naja das hat sich
geändert ja ich hab gesagt
geschlossenheit ja man hat sich hinter
dem spitzenkandidaten olaf scholz
versammelt und man hat auch dessen
programm mit dem er angetreten ist mit
getragen indem man auf jeden fall
endlich auch dagegen agiert hat man hat
schien man hat ihn und das war ja auch
klug das hat der zuwachs auch gezeigt
dass hat die popularität von herrn
scholz ja auch gezeigt dass hat auf
jeden fall früchte getragen erinnern bei
unserem steinmeier ans pult ein
steinbrück da war das alles ganz anders
es heißt frage rattay vorsitzenden
saskia essen und wollte norbert walter
borjans haben da ein großes verdienst
weil sie sich selbst hin angestellt
haben haben sie gewiss und auch wir
haben gerade gesehen camping kühler denn
wir dürfen ja nicht vergessen so wohl
eher kühnert wie fresken wie herr walter
born stehen ja für was anderes ist ja
noch nicht ganz so lange her da hat die
spd neuen parteivorsitzenden gewählt und
das ist ja nicht scholz geworden sondern
ersten walter borjans sie sind für
andere inhalte angetreten als scholz das
getan hat dann kühnert steht auch für
was anders so die frage war jetzt wie
lange hält das das ist die spannende
frage wie ist offen ich nehme wahr dass
noch sehr abgestimmt scholz auch wir
hatten schon mal gesagt die tonalität
voll also mütze nicht gegen ihn sagt die
kleinen parteien so ein bisschen grüne
fdp ist scholz hingegangen hat gesagt
nichts kleine parteien das sind unsere
politischen freunde so auf der anderen
seite erleben wir natürlich die neue
juso vorsitzende jessica rosenthal die
ins parlament eingezogen ist die schon
relativ klar gemacht hat also was die
fdp sich dabei steuern vorstellt so
läuft das nicht oder eben also
steuererhöhungen ist wichtig und nicht
entlastung da sind so die erste news
natürlich schon wieder ein bisschen sich
wenig sagen die finanzen aber darauf
will ich hinaus es ist schon zu erwarten
und das war die kühnheit intervention
kurz vor der wahl der lindner dann mal
eben so nonchalant als luftikus
bezeichnet hat und dass das
parteiprogramm letztlich nicht tauge sie
werden schon jetzt erleben dass diese
dass diese geschlossenheit mit
sicherheit doch wieder ein stückweit
weichen wird was jetzt das spektrum
erkennbar wird okay oder lasst diese
nutzen natürlich erkennbar werden und da
wird es natürlich schwierig vor allem
weil sie ja die junge ansprechen und wir
haben knapp ein viertel dieser 200 und 6
abgeordneten der spd knapp über 50 sind
ja junge die da eingezogen sind die er
wahrscheinlich auch in anführungszeichen
inhaltlichen druck ausüben werden und
dann schon irgendwann in den nächsten
wochen monaten doch spätestens auf den
plan kommen sagen sekunde sekunde
sekunde wir wollen jene inhalte die im
zweifel deutlich ich nenne es mal etwas
einfach linker sind als das was
vielleicht olaf scholz zusammen mit der
fdp verhandeln würde die grünen gibt es
natürlich auch noch
und die vor allen dingen um das mal
abzubilden koalitionspolitisch er auf
rot grün rot gesetzt haben als jetzt auf
die ampel und genau das ist natürlich
der spannende punkt und das war auch
schon der kinder tun was na ja bei einem
koalitionsvertrag im zweifelsfalle
befragen wir die mitglieder das ist dann
natürlich schon heiko scholz weiß das
ist das wagnis der spd und das ist ein
super die offene flanke und deswegen ist
noch gar nicht ausgemacht dass jetzt
ganz klar alles auf yamaha ampel zuläuft
und das ist ende auch alles gut klappt
minden hat die fdp beobachten sehr genau
so wie wir das jetzt auch tun sehr genau
wer meldet sich wie mit welchem inhalt
in der spd jetzt zu wort in welche
richtung geht das steht man wirklich
hinter scholz kann man das verfahren zu
nehmen oder ist ein stückweit könig ohne
land klar limes zu verdanken dass die
spd zugelegt hat aber letztendlich war
das nur so ne das war wirklich nur so
eine abmachung laufzeit und dann kommt
doch wieder die alte die bekannte spd
zum vorschein auf die hat weder lindner
im zweifel zeller habe keine lust keine
lust und wahrscheinlich auch weniger
einfluss der professor kronberg sehr
spannend meine damen und herren das
einmal so jetzt auch hier morgen noch
nicht so diskutiert und die frage die
eben broker kronberg auch ein
geschmissen hat von wegen gibt es dann
eine mitgliederbefragung möglicherweise
über eine zukünftige mögliche koalition
die grünen haben das schon angedacht da
gibt's schon ein antrag dass sie ihre
mitglieder dann am ende entscheiden
lassen würden über einen potenziellen
koalitionsantrag da lohnt sich doch mal
der blick auf grüne und linke wollen
schon fast an grüne und fdp und die
frage was trennt er eigentlich die
beiden die zusammen kommen müssen und wo
gibt es gemeinsamkeiten
betrachtet man die wahlprogramme von
grünen und fdp so lassen sie sich
scheinbar leicht zu einem gesamtbild
zusammenfügen auf den zweiten blick wird
es komplizierter
thema klima die grünen wollen tempolimit
130 den kohleausstieg auf 20 30
vorziehen und ab dann nur noch komplett
emissionsfreie autos zu lassen die fdp
möchte kein tempolimit kohleausstieg bei
20 38 erstmal belassen und auf die
innovationskraft der autoindustrie
vertrauen ein kompromiss thema könnte
der emissionshandel sein auf denen setzt
die fdp als instrument des marktes wohl
den grünen könnte es die chance bieten
durch teure zertifikate den co2 preis zu
erhöhen gut fürs klima auch zwischen den
parteien thema geld die fdp will auf
keinen fall die schuldenbremse
aufweichen und auch nicht die steuern
erhöhen die grünen wollen geld für
klimaschutz investitionen und die
steuern für kleinere und mittlere
einkommen senken für größere einkommen
und vermögen anheben hier ist ein
kompromiss schwierig möglich sind aber
wohl klima investitionen die über
sonderwege finanziert werden also nicht
gegen die schuldenbremse verstoßen und
dann noch das thema gesundheit hier
wollen die grünen eine
bürgerversicherung für alle einführen
die fdp am bestehenden system von
privaten und gesetzlichen kassen
festhalten einigung in diesem punkt wohl
schwierig
als bürgerliche parteien gibt es
allerdings auch gemeinsames bei den
bürgerrechten der gleichberechtigung der
digitalen bildung dem datenschutz der
integration den wählerschichten und
wahrscheinlich auch dem wunsch bald
endlich wieder zu regieren
auf die inhaltlichen überschneidungen
von grünen und linken wollen wir gerne
jetzt schauen zusammen mit gerhard baum
dem letzten bundesinnenminister denen
die fdp in einer regierung gestellt hat
vor knapp 40 jahren in der spd geführten
regierung von helmut schmidt 1978 bis 82
für muntari baum
guten morgen herr warum sie haben die
zusammenarbeit mit den grünen gestern
nacht bei meinem kollegen markus lanz im
zdf als projekt bezeichnet was ist für
sie ein projekt
ja also beide parteien sind nicht teil
der großen koalition gewesen sie stehen
also nicht für den status quo sondern
für etwas neues und sehr interessant ist
dass sie bei jung und erstwählern sehr
gut abgeschnitten haben sie haben einen
zukunft zu auftrag das heißt also sie
müssen jetzt die linien bestimmen über
die einzelheiten wird man dann im
einzelnen auch streiten aber die die nie
muss stimmen dass wir die zukunft
sichern in sachen umwelt europa an all
den themen die jetzt dringend behandelt
werden müssen und es kommt noch etwas
hinzu was soll denn passieren wenn die
beiden jetzt scheitern dann ist ja im
grunde der welt alles in sich zusammen
das heißt sie sind auch in gewisser
hinsicht zu einem erfolg verurteilt und
ich sehe die chancen gar nicht so
schlecht denn es bewegt sich etwas in
der gesellschaft die neue parteien
struktur wird sichtbar es ist eine
vielfalt die uns jetzt hier begegnen in
der gesellschaft sind riesen probleme in
der welt in europa in deutschland alles
ist ein 1 1 mutti war eine motivation
jetzt ein projekt zu machen also nicht
nur einzelne forderungen abzuhaken
sondern das in ein gesamtkonzept zu
wiesen in eine richtungsentscheidung für
die zukunft und sie sagen sie sagen
wahrzeichen von roche linien herr baum
was sind denn diese großen linien wo sie
sagen da sind grüne und fdp auf einer
linie und wo sagen sie nein da ist man
doch weit voneinander entfernt da muss
man sich erst auf eine linie einigen
da muss da muss man sich auf eine linie
einigen zum beispiel spannungsverhältnis
was macht der markt was macht der staat
ich sehe da keine
unüberwindbare hinderungsgründe es ist
ja jetzt das ziel beispielsweise die
umweltkatastrophe zu vermeiden da geht
es darum wie erreicht man das ziel am
besten und da meine ich musste sich
beide bewegen der markt schafft licht
alles aber mit regeln wird man auch
nicht alles schafft man braucht die die
kräfte der wirtschaft die kräfte die
idee das einzelne individuum aufbringen
muss und um die zukunft mitzugestalten
also ich bin wirklich relativ
optimistisch er wird und ja es ist doch
schon mal ein guter anfang haben wir
nicht da rein gretchen darf bleiben wir
doch mal ganz konkret also hast du die
fdp sagt ganz klar schuldenbremse bleibt
die grünen sagen ja auch wir wollen die
schuldengrenze nicht auf brennen sie
nicht aufweichen aber wir wollen
deutlich mehr investitionen als das
vielleicht die fdp will wie geht das so
sinnvolle investition will jedoch nicht
weil sie habe von der investitionen in
bildung in unserer infrastruktur wir
wollen sinnvolle investitionen die also
dass das land dauerhaft
in die zukunft bringen und da wird man
sich doch einigen die
siebenbürger schon sicher nicht merken
dass man bereit wenn ich da kurz rein
greifen darf wenn wir ist es bei der
krankenversicherung da möchte die
möchten die grünen gerne eine
bürgerversicherung also alle zahlen in
die gleiche krankenversicherung ein
während sie während die fdp ganz nah
sagt nein dieses system gesetzliche und
private krankenversicherungen das wollen
wir so beibehalten das ist ja ein
diametralen gegensatz ja
ja das wird schwierig und da wird man
genau rechnen müssen und man wird auch
prinzipien zur disposition stellen wir
haben eine andere annäherung an die an
die lösung als die grünen und dass das
sind ich will gar nicht verschweigen es
gibt auch schwierige probleme aber ich
glaube die tatsache dass man sich jetzt
von eingefahrenen gleisen weg bewegen
musste etwas gemeinsam zu etwas neuem
dieser druck ist da und wenn die
parteien das bestehen sozusagen die
beiden kleineren als nukleus der neuen
koalition dann wird ihnen das beiden
helfen und edi und weiter voranbringen
ich bin fest überzeugt
dieser druck der jetzt auch der
zeitliche druck der besteht wird zur
lösung führen ich meine den druck habe
es vorher vier jahren ja auch damals hat
man sich dann trotzdem nicht gar ein ich
beziehungsweise christian lindner hat
trotzdem zurückgezogen was sagt denn uns
allen wer sagt denn uns allen jetzt dass
christian lindner nicht dass dieses jahr
wieder so macht
das scheitern von jamaika ist ein trauma
und es bestimmt auch jetzt den gang der
dinge man will auf keinen fall sich so
verhält wie das 2017 geschehen ist das
ist auch ein gutes vorzeichen mann willi
fehler vermeiden nicht wollen dass das
gilt auch für die für die spd man wird
jetzt genau ich aufpassen müssen was
passiert eigentlich in den fraktionen
nicht wahr die vielen neuen mitglieder
bei der bei der spd beispielsweise sind
die einen unsicherheitsfaktor was
passiert bei den grünen liegen die fdp
ist ziemlich stabil also geben wir jetzt
mal davon aus dass es eine kanzlei
scholz gibt aber das ist ja auch noch
nicht aus gehören er baue ich mein sie
haben ja einst den linksliberalen
freiburger kreis innerhalb der fdp
gegründet ich gehe also wahrscheinlich
recht in der annahme dass sie
wahrscheinlich doch die ampel er
präferiere jamaika ist es aus ihrer
sicht so dass wenn es hier nicht zu
einer ampel kommt und zu einer einigung
dann steht für sie auch christian
lindner als parteichef infrage
das steht überhaupt nicht zur debatte
manchmal
wird sich wie die anderen bemühen jetzt
zu einer einigung zu kommen ich mache
keinen hehl aus meiner meinung ich war
immer ein anhänger des sozialen
liberalismus wie dem in dem freibad
legendären freiburger programm vor 50
jahren das zum ausdruck gekommen ist
also mit mit auch mit kritik überhaupt
an auswüchse des kapitalismus und wir
waren die erste umweltpartei ich war ja
auch umweltminister
das kann und muss man meines erachtens
wiederbeleben das wird der fdp gut tun
inwiefern gut tun
weil sie weil sie ihr jetzt sichtbar
ihre thematische spektrum wieder
arbeiter das hat sie schon längst getan
in der fraktion gibt es kräftige jüngere
kräfte
fachleute menschen die sich engagieren
auf dem feld der umweltpolitik der
bürgerrechte und so weiter die jetzt die
jetzt ja auch sichtbarer werden die fdp
hat die zeit genutzt der opposition und
es ist eine eine eine führungsriege
nachgewachsen die jetzt auch sichtbarer
werden wird und sichtbarer werden muss
gerhart baum wenn ich das liebevoll
sagen darf ein urgestein der fdp fehlen
dann gehen herr baum hier im phoenix
tagesgespräch
ja noch schönen tag
also interessantes gespräch mit gerd
baum der natürlich nicht dabei ist im
inneren zirkel so ein bisschen die
groben linien beschrieben hat trotzdem
blieb das ist die frage über ok also
grobe linien sind ja schön und gut aber
wie groß bleiben am ende eben die
differenzen im detail die am ende dann
vielleicht doch wieder zu auch wenn das
am heutigen tag überhaupt nicht so
aussieht richtung jamaika oder zumindest
möglichen gesprächen auch mit der union
führen können
ich glaube der bauarbeiten im gespräch
sehr schön deutlich geworden und das war
der punkt von gerhart baum es geht schon
um es geht um vertrauen es gibt schon um
die langen linien es geht um den willen
etwas gemeinsam machen zu wollen dass
zwar seinen eingangs hinweis beide
parteien grün wie gelb es kommen aus der
opposition sind im grunde jetzt mal frei
von dem was man da eben zu verantworten
hat in den letzten jahren weil das
schleppt die spd ein stück weit auch mit
sich sie stellt sie ihr jetzt wollte sie
im grunde jetzt auch den aufbruch aber
sie hat ja eben auch mit regiert das mit
zu verantworten beide wollen eine reform
ja was ein reform jahrzehnt eine eine
ära begründen und hauptmann dass jetzt
gleich das projekt nennen will weiß ich
jetzt nicht weil dafür ist man doch sehr
verschieden und war doch mal war doch
eher mehr auch opposition untereinander
bei der der punkt ist der
es geht um das vertrauen der akteure ist
geht tatsächlich um das identifizieren
dieser längeren linien worauf wir uns
dann konzentrieren was sollen wir denn
zum gemeinsamen machen dass die junge
generation das die nachhaltigkeit da ist
das klima da ist die
generationengerechtigkeit und wenn man
das dann unterbricht darüber eben schon
gesprochen dann ist man bei bildung dann
ist man bei bildungschancen weil es mal
bildungsgerechtigkeit da kann die spd
schon mit kinder können die grünen mit
gehen da kann die fdp anknüpfen und von
daher gesehen ist jetzt die situation
offen und was wir eben erleben das haben
wir auch gesagt dass die beiden jetzt
ist die ersten gespräche untereinander
für das ist ganz anders als 2017 und
insofern ist das sicherlich sehr
verheißungsvoll
jetzt kommt das aber es ist tatsächlich
noch überhaupt nicht klar dass die reise
richtung ampel geht wünscht sich dass
seit jahrzehnten in die wolle gefärbter
sozialliberaler aber wenn das holz ist
könig ohne land und der kühler geht
woanders hin und die es geht woanders
hin und die jusos gehen woanders hin
dann ist das fundament nicht da dann ist
das vertrauen nicht da dann ist auch das
große projekt nicht da und dann wird man
auch mal ganz neu beleuchten müssen die
jugend war heute vormittag hier bei uns
schon häufiger ein thema wir haben aber
noch nicht intensiv genug finde ich
darüber gesprochen noch mal die frage
grüne und liberale
waren sehr sehr stark bei den jungen
wählern haben da sogar eine mehrheit
insgesamt unter den jüngeren was
bedeutet das denn ist das eine basis an
sich wenn junge menschen sowohl die ein-
als auch die anderen gerne mögen oder
heißt das überhaupt nicht sondern heißt
nur dass die junge gesellschaft in
deutschland eben sehr geteilt ist die
einen wollen lieber die liberalen halb
konservativen und die anderen wollen er
die linken jung wirkenden
es ist eine chance ohne junge wähler
werden sich die parteien schwer tun
natürlich stellen die jungen die 18 bis
24 jährigen sie haben völlig recht beide
parteien grüne wie fdp haben immer also
wir haben jeweils zehn prozent zugelegt
und liegen damit im anteil auf platz
eins und zwei aber in der
gesamtbevölkerung sind die jungen 18 bis
24 jährigen natürlich bei weitem nicht
die mehrheit das sind die l aber es ist
eine chance denn im grunde da der mann
die an sich bindet längerfristig dann
ist das natürlich ein wichtiges
potenzial die kämen die grünen wie gelb
adressieren wie bildung die
digitalisierung und und anderes das sind
themen natürlich auch umweltschutz und
klima und nachhaltigkeit das sind das
sind themen die die grünen bewegt haben
übrigens auch die tatsache dass fdp wie
grüne vergleichsweise junge
spitzenkandidaten ja hatten dann auch
dass sie ihre jeweiligen wahlkämpfe sehr
stark in den sozialen netzwerken ja dort
konzentriert hatten
und das ist sicherlich ein potenzial
über die themen und begriffe die ich
gerade genannt habe um hier auch
sozusagen einerseits die jungen an sich
zu binden chance und eben aber auch hier
diese gemeinsamkeiten auszuloten will
also heißen tablets in die schule
tablets in den unterricht mehr digitaler
unterricht das ist ja nicht etwas was
grün und gelb jetzt mal eben sechs
wochen in der heißen phase des
wahlkampfs erkannt haben sondern seit
jahren und da sind sie nah beieinander
in den fokus stellen und da kann man was
draus machen und wenn die beiden nichts
draus machen dann ist die frage ob steht
dann die union doch bereit hat sie
zumindest gesagt aber die fragezeichen
bleiben natürlich bei all den
diskussionen die da in den letzten tagen
auch um den kanzlerkandidaten und
parteivorsitzenden armin laschet
entstanden sind
die wortwahl auf der wand sagt schon
alles csu im bundestag manche in der cdu
regt allein das auf schließlich sei man
doch eine fraktion eine union csu chefs
würde aber lässt kaum eine gelegenheit
aus gegen den glücklosen
kanzlerkandidaten armin laschet zu
sticheln noch dazu geriert er sich als
retter der union in der so söder gerade
große nervosität und anspannung
herrschen da wird so unsere aufgabe sein
in dieser aufgeregten zeit auch in der
union stückweit ordnung und linien und
vertrauen und zusammenhalt zu
stabilisieren sich von der kleineren
schwester den takt vorgeben lassen
diese machtbewusste ansage kommt in der
cdu gar nicht gut an die cdu ist selber
stabil wir haben starke
ministerpräsidenten von schleswig
holstein bis sachsen oder saarland wir
haben mehrere führungspersonen auch in
der cdu bundestagsfraktion
und deswegen brauchen wir keine weitere
unterstützung aus bayern für die
stabilisierung der union nach den
dramatischen verlusten am sonntag sind
natürlich beide unionsschwestern
verantwortlich und zuständig das ist
eine gemeinschaftsaufgabe die wir auch
gemeinsam bewältigen müssen das mit der
gemeinsamkeit von cdu/csu scheint so
eine sache zu sein wahlkampfabschluss
der union vergangenen freitag da war die
hoffnung noch groß und die welt in
ordnung jetzt herrscht katerstimmung und
mit der geselligkeit ist es vorbei
sprechen wir mit eckart lohse dem leiter
der parlamentsredaktion der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung hallo herr lohse
herr lohse sprechen wir über das
stichwort einigkeit ist ja vielleicht so
was wie ein überbegriff über diese tage
nach der bundestagswahl bleiben gerne
bei der union die wir eben auch im
beitrag gesehen haben also einigkeit
besteht ja da nicht allzu viel zu geben
wie bewerten sie das was gerade in der
union passiert
so man hat das ja schon in den letzten
drei jahren sehen können die einigkeit
ging verloren als angela merkel
angekündigt hat dass sie nicht mehr
vorsitzen sein will aber noch drei jahre
kanzlerin und seit dieser strecke hat
die union ist nicht mehr geschafft im
streit zwischen cdu und csu aber auch
innerhalb der cdu eine einige linie zu
finden jetzt eskaliert das ja geradezu
erst mit der im streit über die
kanzlerkandidatur die söder und leicht
beide haben wollten und jetzt nach dem
schlechten wahlergebnis wird es
eigentlich immer dramatischer vor allen
dingen von csu seiten von söder seiten
aus dass er immer wenn vielleicht ein
bisschen beruhigung einkehrt sofort die
wunde wieder aufreißt ich kann es auch
verstehen dass alle parteien sagen da
werden wir skeptisch ob wir mit denen
überhaupt solide vorhanden führen können
weil wir gar nicht genau wissen wir
hatten da eigentlich prokura bei denen
es ist ja so weit gegangen dass gestern
abend volker wissing der generalsekretär
der fdp im heute journal gesagt hat also
diese einladung die die fdp an die union
ausgesprochen hat sich am samstag zu
treffen zudem würde es wohl nicht kommen
weil die union ich zitiere das mal zeit
probleme hätte oder auch eine satirische
probleme wie kann das sein wie kann an
einem samstag etwas wichtigeres geben
für die union als ich mit der fdp über
mögliche sondierung für die zukunft zu
unterhalten ja das kann überhaupt nicht
sein das kann höchstens sein dass nicht
klar ist wer in der union diese
verhandlungen dann führt wer die nummer
eins ist die frage wird ja auch immer
wieder gestellt armin laschet
beansprucht natürlich diese rolle für
sich er war der kanzlerkandidat er kann
das überhaupt nur machen aber wenn wir
die worte söders von vorgestern uns noch
mal in erinnerung bringen dann hat er ja
auch deutlich gemacht dass die csu dass
er da eine rolle sich vorstellen kann er
war war zwar von einer matrix die rede
die die csu bereits für solche
verhandlungen habe das ist natürlich so
etwas öffentlich vorzutragen bevor der
kanzlerkandidat etwas dazu sagt ist
natürlich auch eine provokation und
nur so kann es zu solchen
schwierigkeiten kommen also braucht man
armin laschet jetzt noch für diese
gespräche mit der fdp weil eben auch
dieses verhältnis verhältnis laschet
lindner so eng ist und danach ist am
bett
also eins ist ja klar jetzt braucht man
ihn auf jeden fall wenn die union jetzt
als die cdu dann die csu zweifel daran
aufkommen lässt wer da der
kanzlerkandidat war wer der vorsitzende
ist und wer solche gespräche ganz gleich
wohin sie führen führt ich glaube dann
muss sie gar nicht mehr sich um
gesprächspartner bemühen es muss klar
sein dass das ohne streit dass man ohne
streit zumindest diese ersten
sondierungen führt das scheint ja schon
schwierig zu sein was dann daraus so das
ist höchst ungewiss übrigens hört man
das ja auch in der cdu schon dass das
die hoffnung dass ist zu einer jamaika
koalition kommt nicht gerade wachsen im
moment aber wenn jetzt eine demontage
müller schätzt die ja gegen dessen
willen stattfände käme also dann wäre
der streit perfekt und dann würde ich
glaube ich jede partei gesagt mit denen
lieber nicht verhandeln würde ich
verstehen guck mal von der union weg und
schauen mal zu den beiden neuen man
denkt ja fast schon lieblingspartnern
grünen und fdp wie groß ist denn die
einigkeit tatsächlich in den letzten
wochen monaten vielleicht auch jahren
geworden nach diesem eklat 2017 als
christian lindner sich hier aus den
sondierungsgesprächen aus den gesprächen
zu einer neuen koalition zurückgezogen
hat man habe immer gesprächskontakt
gehalten man hat natürlich
in beiden parteien gewusst sie sehen ja
auch die zahlen dass die möglichkeit
eines dreierbündnisses nach der wahl
jetzt
vorhanden ist das war klar ist
zwischenzeitlich mal nach option
schwarz-grün aus aber man kann sich ja
darauf vorbereiten dreierbündnis ist
möglich daher immer kontakte gehalten
werden sie haben es ja eben in der
sendung auch schon aufgearbeitet es gibt
natürlich einige inhaltliche differenzen
einige schnittstellen gerade die
rechtspolitik die rechtsstaats politik
da ist manches wo man zusammenkommen
kann bildungspolitik aber es gibt
natürlich beisteuern sozialpolitik da
ist es fraglich es gab in der
asylpolitik große unterschiede aber
vergessen wenn ich zwei jahre nach dem
großen
flüchtlingsstreit 215 haben ja fdp und
grüne 217 miteinander verhandelt und
gescheitert ist das ganze nicht daran
dass die beiden sich zerlegt haben
sondern dass lindner angst hatte dass
die damals einige cdu unter angela
merkel sich zu sehr auf die grünen
einlässt ist war aber nicht das
hauptproblem dass fdp und grünen nicht
zusammen kommen also da teile ich die
einschätzung von ihrem gesprächspartner
gerhart baum eben das wendischen
hinkriegen aber doch immer die gleiche
wollte ich eben auch gerd baum gestellt
haben die sich dann doch auch an ihre
ausführungen doch anlehnt nämlich die
frage wer sagt uns denn dass christa
menton nicht diesmal wieder das gleiche
gespür und gefühle hat somalia spd und
grüne sicherheit näher sind als cdu und
grüne damals 2017 union und grüne 2017
der riesen unterschied ist zwischen
lindner und merkel bestand ein
ausgesprochen spannungsreiches
verhältnis
vor allen dingen merkel hatte einen sehr
negativen blick auf lindner das wusste
er
das verhältnis war angespannt und
lindner hatte angst dass die mächtige
cdu chefin und kanzlerin ihn als 5 670
rad am wagen behandelt das ist jetzt
ganz anders erstens lindner laschet
haben ein gutes verhältnis nicht zuletzt
durch das regieren in
nordrhein-westfalen in einer
schwarz-gelben regierung zweitens wenn
es überhaupt weitere schritte geben
sollte über sondierungen hinaus laschet
ist natürlich geschwächt dh die sorge
lindners von damals die bügeln uns unter
die ist natürlich geringer aber dann
dachte und die letzte frage wie ist es
dann um die spd mit den beiden also wie
eng ist das verhältnis von olaf scholz
zu christian lindner beispielsweise in
diesem sinne nicht so eng wie zwischen
laschet und lindner aber wir kennen alle
christian lindner und das weiss man
übrigens in der cdu auch ganz genau
lindner ist dann pragmatiker weiß dass
es nicht sehr gut kenne und
wahrscheinlich bedrohlich für ihn würde
wenn er nochmal so etwas machte wie vor
vier jahren plötzlich abspringen aus
verhandlungen christian lindner ist
clever genug dann auch ein zusammengehen
mit der spd als großes projekt zu
verkaufen also das traue ich ihm
durchaus zu auch wenn sein verhältnisse
scholz nicht so eng ist wie zu löschen
da ist es wieder dieses wort projekt was
gerhard baum schon geprägt hat eckart
lohse vielen dank ihr leiter der
parlamentsredaktion der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung vielen dank für die
hintergründe werden
so ist das an diesem tag habe ich ja
heute morgen schon gesagt alles ist im
fluss und so entwickelt sich natürlich
so ein tag dann auch weiter jetzt wissen
wir dass die union einen termin gefunden
hat mit der fdp zumindest schon mal zu
sprechen das soll am sonntagabend um 18
uhr 30 sein so berichten mehrere
nachrichtenagenturen und medien und
warum das dann nicht am samstag geklappt
hat wofür sie eigentlich vorgesehen war
das liegt also berichtet dass zumindest
die tageszeitung die welt daran dass
markus söder der csu-chef nicht kann
weil am freitagabend der achtzigsten
geburtstag von edmund stoiber ansteht
und am samstag die csu basiskonferenz
oder ist man offenbar bei der cdu und
fdp davon ausgegangen dass man nicht
schon verschieden könnte
andererseits hat markus söder wohl
gesagt die verschiebe ich nicht was sagt
uns dass herr professor kronberg ist
dass fehlendes interesse von markus
söder ist das bloß nicht die möglichkeit
armin laschet zu geben da doch noch
irgendwie als der macher aufzutreten
es ist sicherlich zweiter bauers
eigensinn ich meine das setzt sich fort
wir haben es gerade auch noch mal von
eckart lohse ja gehört und das
beobachten wir schon lange wir haben oft
im studio gestanden und waren hochgradig
irritiert über das verhalten der csu
ende im wahlkampf und das hat sich
natürlich verschärft nach dem debakel
vom sonntag fort und das ganze ist
natürlich tatsächlich
wenig hilfreich für für für armin
laschet denn so eine basiskonferenz
dauert natürlich nicht verborgen dass
sie den tiefen abend da findet man
sicherlich wegen ein hier war der klare
botschaft aber ich bin herr eigener herr
über meinen terminkalender und b
tatsächlich dass das nehme ich ernst
basis csu denn wir dürfen nicht
vergessen die cs ist ja nicht wirklich
viel stärker ja 35 prozent wenn jetzt in
bayern als erfolg gefeiert wo der inhalt
ein prozent weniger als 2007 damals 6,2
bundesweit jetzt 5,2 sodann denken wenn
die kommunalwahl denken wenn die
europawahl die letzte landtagswahl oder
was soll da jetzt bei wahlen bei wahlen
zeigt ist natürlich nicht besonders
starken das ist natürlich ausdruck
dieser strategie laschet ist schuld der
war es ja schon so schult bevor ob die
wahl stattgefunden hat also das ganze
lässt aufhorchen insofern bin ich bei
dem was was der kategorie sagt auch die
die unsicherheit wird ja immer größer
und ich würde sagen beachtlich war ja
eigentlich das lindener die hand
gereicht hat ja bis bis gestern ja
gesagt hat wir sprechen erst mit euch da
wir da wird die unsicherheit da wären
die fragezeichen natürlich immer größer
wie gesprächsfähig ist denn überhaupt
die union und daraus ist immer auch
nichts geworden volker grünberg vielen
dafür sprechen nachher nochmal weiter
meine damen und herren nutzen mal die
möglichkeit hier einmal kurz
durchzuatmen mit dem blick dann doch
noch mal zurück gerne auch auf die
letzten jahre angela merkel 16 jahre
kanzlerschaft in den letzten 16 jahren
und da haben wir drauf geschaut mit acht
auslandskorrespondenten aus 8 ländern
danach sind wir wieder da eine etwa
einer viertelstunde ein bisschen weniger
und sprechen mit reinhard bütikofer im
europaparlament über das wie vielleicht
auch europa auf diese bundestagswahl
schaut
[Musik]
diese raute ganz viele auch ukrainische
politiker haben das nach gemacht
in force angela merkel ist
[Musik]